welcome to development control be today
my name is Cathy Guthrie and I'm the
Chairman's a day and I've lost
encryption now first of all remind you
of some domestic arrangements toilets
are situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the Ipswich Town Football
Club training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you're told this is safe
to do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to silent I would
like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you have
finished so we now move to the agenda so
apologies for absence and substitutions
please take your chair we have one
apology for today and one substitution
of counsel Mike Norris has given his
apologies don't count Stanfield is
substituting for thank you to receive
any declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members no
declarations of lobbying i've been
lobbied on item 1 3 & 5 it's not about
the same for everyone else or anything
different councillor Matheson
oh that was it yes thank you
declarations of personal site visits
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on July the 10th 2019 and I
will just state that its pages 1 to 14
and are there any amendments please
now I shall sign them during the meeting
if I may is everybody happy with that
thank you very much to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme none
received you thank you now the schedule
of planning applications I was going to
run it in the order in which in which it
came but because we've got members of
the public who are here who wish to
speak and have come as supporters and
objectives and the biggest ones for
those have to be in my area of Dublin so
what we propose to do is do items 7 a
first and then item 7e as the second
item and then we'll run in the order in
which it goes so the first application
is Vincent Pierce who's going to or I
will don't introduce everybody hello
there I'm too excited
introductions legal officer in de crane
John Pape and G senior planning officer
myself Kathy Guthrie Robert Carmichael
who's the committee officer and Jamie
who's going to be steering our videoing
today we've got officers over there we
have ward members here most importantly
here we have the elected members who
will debate and vote good ladies and
gentlemen in the area at the back some
of your objective supporters parish
council members those who've been asked
and are allocated to speak have three
minutes and the ward members down here
have
longer they can speak but not vote so we
will now move on we've got a global
update thank you just before we begin in
respect of all items being presented
today I just like to update everybody
that they're following the management
review Phillip Isabel is no longer
acting chief planning officer he is now
chief planning officer so in all the
recommendations if it refers to
corporate manager refers to acting chief
planning officer that needs to be
updated we're doing this verbally now to
become chief planning officer for the
purposes of the correct recommendation
so that applies to all the applications
before members today thank you that's
very good news thank you very much
indeed
so Vincent if you would like to open the
first case on page 19 for those of you
who have paper copies and if you'd like
to make presentation thank you very much
thank you Jake good morning members
ladies and gentlemen the first item this
morning is land at Church Road in
Gipping Road stove upland and what we're
looking at is a full application for
effectively some amended units from an
earlier reserved matters approval and an
additional 19 units I will explain that
a little bit more detail as we go
through the slides because it is a bit
confusing to start with so the phase two
reserved matters permission gave us
details for 100 units what we're looking
at in a way is an amendment of that
reserved matters permission what we're
currently looking at is in the blue
there are 53 plots that we're looking at
some sort of amendment on 47 will remain
unchanged from the earlier reserved
matters approval so before you this
morning 53 amended plots
however the application which is a full
application also includes
19 additional units so the difference
between the previous phase to reserved
matters approval and what you're looking
at this morning is a total of 19 units
the application site is shown in red on
the screen the area in blue is the area
which benefits from an outline planning
permission for 175 dwellings so within
the area red there is reserved matters
approval for 100 units there is an
earlier phase which has nothing to do
with this proposal is 75 units which is
already being built out that gives you
the 175
another way of describing that is on the
left the outline the original outline
catered for up to 175 dwellings what
you're now looking at the area in red
includes 19 additional units
so overall the site will now comprise if
it was approved 194 dwellings rather
than 175 members who are familiar with
the site will know that development is
advanced well advanced on the site and
I've tried to indicate on that slide in
the yellow color where development is
already proceeding if we take a quick
flight from Stowe market through to
Stowe up and the site starts to appear
in the middle of the screen and you'll
see us this zooms in some of the
development that is already underway
just let that slide work its way through
you can start to see the buildings in
the bottom half of the middle of the
screen
there's another shot a very recent shot
so you can see how much development has
already occurred so we're really looking
at the right-hand side of that that
screen some of the development that has
already taken place
in terms of constraints the principle
one is just to the top of that map is
Columbine or listed building but
obviously the previous permissions have
all been granted in the knowledge of the
existence of that listed building to the
north important to recognize that Stowe
upland does have an adopted neighborhood
plan and the interesting thing to note
the area edged blue in the sort of
purple color within the neighborhood
plan is this site it is recognized
obviously the planning permission has
been granted and that is now suggested
and included within the settlement
boundary within the neighborhood plan in
terms of your emerging local plan very
similar scenario the era aged blue is
intended should it be approved
ultimately to be within the settlement
boundary for Stowe upland which is not
it's not unsurprising in view of the
fact that there is an extent permission
and it is being built out
there's a shot of the proposed site
layout we're looking more detail at
where the changes are occurring but what
I wanted to show you on this slide is
that the area edged gray is not within
this application but what you'll notice
is there is a significant area around
this site which is already being
developed and will be development
developed under earlier permission so in
a way this is a sort of a donut and the
outer ring of the donut is untouched by
proposals within this application the
other thing to note is that existing
dwellings are all on that side of the
site so already there will be a buffer
between existing residents and the area
which is subject to proposed amendments
simply by dint of the fact that there is
development between the two and that
development has been approved and will
be built so here we have a layout
comparison so this is the current
proposal the full proposal the units
shown in light blue are the units being
proposed if I just flick will
superimpose the earlier reserved matters
you may have difficulty in spotting the
difference but as we go through I will
draw your specific attention to that the
changes but the point I'm making is that
whilst there's an increase in numbers of
19 units it is very hard in the overall
layout to discern where those changes
are
in fact what you see there is within the
area edged green there will be an uplift
of five units and with thee within the
area edged orangey-brown there will be
14 additional units that area in brown
also extends southwards and includes
that part as well so the five and the 14
gives you the increase of 19 units all
within the heart of an existing approved
development so where are the changes so
if we look at that northern section
you'll notice the roads haven't changed
the outer edges of the curtilage is
haven't changed and it is still quite
difficult to spot where the changes but
we will go into more detail and here I
start to go into detail so what how have
blue Holmes managed to increase the
number of units by 19 without changing
the overall footprint of the application
site well here's an example so if we
take the top that is the same unit so
that unit hasn't changed we go back one
there you'll see that a large detached
house has been substituted with two
semi-detached houses so they've put in
smaller units but in terms of the
footprint on the site those
semi-detached units take up the same
space almost as the house so in terms of
what impact will they have visually I
would say no impact whatsoever because
the mass of the building in that part of
the site is the same
there you'll see that unit has been
shifted northwards which has allowed one
extra unit to be put in where the black
outlined arrow is but in terms of the
feel of the street UI I would suggest
you wouldn't notice that change but that
has already allowed two additional units
to be put into that very short section
of the street and in terms of the bottom
of the site change of house type but
it's still the same depth of plot what
blue have daddies go around the whole of
that application air and just make those
subtle adjustments taking out bigger
units and slipping in some smaller units
in order to increase the number of units
and actually I would suggest that
creates a better mix of units in terms
of the sizes of units that you as a
committee like to to see and I will go
into more detail shortly so there's a
typical street scene as proposed this
morning and that character is identical
to the character of the rest of the the
estate so much so that here are some of
the proposed units within the
application site this morning there is a
significant number of bungalows which a
number of members have asked offices to
ensure that we can try and get as many
bungalows as possible within this
proposal the number of bungalows has
increased so all of those can be found
on the rest of the estate there are one
or two variations but overall the house
types are the same so we're not looking
at a situation where you're being asked
to consider complete new house types
this is just a swapping of houses within
that central core previously all the
house types were considered acceptable
so I can see no reason to suggest that
adjusting those would be anything other
than acceptable
so here we have a an analysis of the
change of mix so in terms of the flats
which were previously approved there is
no change to the proposed number of
units but you'll notice in terms of
two-bedroom bungalows there is an
increase of 6 some members will find
that a positive because we're increasing
the number of units available either for
people who are downsizing I want to live
on one floor and avoid stairs in terms
of three-bedroom bungalows there is a
reduction but overall that's an increase
by 3 in a number of bungalows within
this part of the site the biggest
changes are an increase in the number of
2 bit and 3 bit houses and I can record
from recent committees members have
suggested that we should be looking to
increase the number of three-bedroom
units mid range and try and reduce on
schemes the number of larger houses so
what's happened on this scheme is we
still have 21 four-bedroom houses but
that's a reduction by 8 so all in all
within that adjustment there are 19
additional units so what's happened is
effectively the number of larger units
has reduced which has allowed an
increase in the number of medium to
small sized units largely within the
existing footprints here we have a slide
showing the bungalow so you'll see that
on the northern edge there is a
concentration of bungalows that reflects
the uplift of three units again a good
number of bungalows within this this
proposal
in terms of landscaping everything
that's shown green there is as before no
part of the landscaping or open space
has been eaten into to accommodate the
extra 19 units and the good thing with
this is of course is that all the
structural landscaping is on the
perimeter of the site so that would be
unchanged so I think what I would argue
because the changes are actually in this
sort of core it will be impossible to
spot the changes because of the fact
that you've got the ring of landscaping
then the ring of existing development
you might spot some changes where you go
down these streets but in real terms you
will be it will be very difficult to
spot the changes I would suggest that
neighbours existing properties in here I
wouldn't have any amenity threats posed
by this simply because it's again in
this core area and it has this buffer
and ring around it so so the question is
is another 19 units acceptable the
report draws attention to the fact that
the original consent was granted on
appeal and the inspector had limited the
number of units to 175 up to 175 but
this is a full application so in a sense
you're being asked to consider the
merits of this afresh
so the question you need to I suggest
grapple with this morning is what harm
can you identify from the additional 19
units and if you can't identify any harm
the fact that previously 175 was felt to
be an appropriate ceiling number for
units should that actually carry much
weight if you can't find any harm as a
result our professional advice is there
is no harm from
90 news and in some ways it actually
allows for a mix that better suits the
need within the district in terms of
affordable housing many of you will be
wondering whether or not there has been
a pro rata increase in the number of
affordable units and yes there has
so the additional 19 units will include
the 35% lift for affordable housing the
highway authority have also asked for
some additional financial contributions
towards carrying out some improvements
on the access that's another 10,000
pounds that is also included in the
recommendation so that members it's a
very quick run through the details of
the site thank you thank you for that
before we go to questions from the
members if they do have questions on
this I would like to say it was
unfortunate you weren't at our briefing
because I was assured that it was only
175 houses and your explanation was very
clear there it's pity that hadn't
actually been analyzed in our documents
but you know in in that graph was so
helpful but it's for members to ask the
questions and we have other speakers
obviously so yes counselor Matheson if
you'd like to ask you Thank You Chet
quite a number of years ago I was
involved in a very similar situation to
this on a smaller scale in my ward and
the the the the change from 34 to 52
houses was accepted by the public which
had previously got itself absolutely
nailed down and the 34 was it by the
developer coming through and so we'll
look you said you want more small the
question is quite simple how many
bedrooms were there in the what we
accept already approved and how many are
the now and if we want to leave that one
with the officer for a moment or two to
we'd have to perhaps talk about some
other things
that's useful any further questions
gasps were filled and then counselor
girl thank you yes just a bit of comment
on the number of dwellings oh yeah
perhaps I need to whilst yet again how
many there are here I understood that
the original application for about a
hundred and ninety five was rejected by
us there was an appeal the inspector
reduced the number of dwellings in the
total area of this selected to 175 and I
understood the inspectors decisions were
binding so certain developers or certain
councils allowed to overturn inspectors
decisions or are they actually a bonded
decision and should we be sticking to
175 dwellings in the total area in
respect to the appeal that is a material
consideration for your consideration
there is nothing stopping you in respect
of this application which is a full
application considering it on its merits
and those have been outlined by the case
officer in this case is explained how
they have demonstrated that the
additional 19 can be achieved within
this scheme without harm in officer
opinion whether you agree with that
opinion obviously is the matter of
debate in terms of the inspectors
viewpoint they would have been able be
corrected by the case officers I'm
incorrect as I didn't deal with that
appeal they would have been dealing with
the outline only application at that
time and would not have had the benefit
of detail plans available to them I'm
sure that's a finding but can we pick it
up in debate but I hear what you're
saying but carry on you just say so up
to 175 means up to somewhat bigger
number if we feel like
the questions that's a good cancer field
is a disaster the question I was going
to ask and in view of the answer now add
something to the debate I hope I think
what not to go seeing at the moment
we're just questions no that's why I'm
holding off there from now right so with
that thank you for that
we now have councillor Keith Wellum who
is speaking as a parish counselor
representative because the party is on
the parish council and so he will speak
as a parish counselor at this point now
thank you Thank You chair the parish
council just had a few comments to make
and one of them is that they wish to
point out the response from public realm
on page 29 is inaccurate the conversion
of a meadow to open space is a
suggestion within a totally different
application not this application it's
essential that the play area within this
application should complement the the
play area provision at the village play
park rather than as it says on I think
it's page 29 which I lost it 29 it says
the local area should be able estándar
to accommodate the range of children
likely to be living in this estate in
the future that is not what the parish
council want because they have provided
a new play area for the younger age
range what they wanted this to be part
of the original Blore
phase 2 application and unchanged by
this application not that it
accommodates a full range but it
accommodates the higher age range I
don't think I don't think that is a
material consideration it's just
something we need to make sure that we
don't follow through the recommendation
that public realm are putting forward
because it is inaccurate it's not within
the red line area no no it isn't it's
just outside it's just outside the red
line area if I may in respect of this
application it's not within the red line
it's not I appreciate that might be what
the public we're I'm officer said but
that is a separate entity to this
application right the recommendation
does not make any reference to that play
space I totally agree with what the
officer says my concern is that members
might think that there is all this
additional play the open space that will
come forward it won't if you just want
to hold on for a moment Vincent can just
thank you I understand the point fully
and we do have blue here this morning it
would be my intention to ensure that the
play space that is provided meets the
parish councils requirements so it will
cater for the older children rather than
anything else that the public realm may
suggest I'm happy to sure that happens
we can pick that up in today then so if
you'd like to carry on cancer thank you
I'm always going to say that we have met
with them with laws advisers and the
parish council have met with laws
advisors with me present and the details
are that they have set out our
acceptable details in terms of play
equipment our acceptable to the parish
council now they're concerned about the
density within the area
it seems that 34 units were proposed of
a particular area and now within that
area there are going to be 53 units it's
suggested in paragraph seven four six
[Applause]
right okay in crude terms the density
increases that talks about an increase
of about 10 10 sir also percent within
that area the increase is 56 percent so
you know that's that is quite quite
different from what it's being suggested
the only other concern that the parish
council have is via the chair of the
neighbourhood plan working group and
I'll expand on this in but in my
presentation and that's the changes that
might be that will be necessary at
Gipping Road because some I'll cover
that in my presentation the detail of it
thank you for that so this is unusual we
can have questions as a parish council
representative if anybody has any
questions no in that case thank you very
much we will move on there is no
objective
there's no supporter and we have the
applicant or the agent Sophie wagget
thank you sorry
[Music]
[Music]
good morning chair and counselors my
name is Sophie Waggett and I'm the
planning manager for blue homes may I
thank your officer for his efforts on
this application which is recommended
for approval the site as a whole
already has Planning Commission the full
planning application in front of you
today changes the layout amounts of
developments on select development
parcels within the second phase to
deliver an extra 19 units that lift in
numbers has been achieved by swapping
larger four-bedroom homes for more two
and three-bedroom units suitable for
first home buyers and expanding families
it does not require any more land and
does not encroach into any public open
space as officer reports explains the
density and appearance of the
development will remain much the same as
that which is already approved it simply
makes more efficient use of the space
available
blough homes is on site right now
construction constructing other parcels
of the pre scheme up front up fronts
infrastructure and access already in
place approving this application will
mean that blog can get to work on these
additional additional units without
delay I can confirm that blue Homes has
progressed legal agreement which means
that the obligations on the original
consent such as those provided travel
plan fordable housing and open space
will be equally applicable to the new
units alongside extra funding for
highways there'll also be a
proportionate increase in sale receipts
and new homes bonus arising from the
scheme this application will deliver
significant benefits through the
provision of an extra 19 open market and
affordable homes and three making more
efficient use of land which was already
benefits from planning permission I
therefore respectively ask that your
account that you host this
recommendation and the scheme is
approved today thank you thank you very
much for that does anyone have any
questions
no oh yes cancel please thank you
I'm sure thank you it's simple question
really I'm a believer in need and want
so what's the actual need for the 19
houses thank you and as you may be aware
there's quite a demand for additional
housing within mid Suffolk from what I
understand there are six have 600
households on the waiting list for
affordable housing of which we will be
can contribute contributing to that and
also it will assist with your 5-year
housing land supply and be proactive in
delivering that on the site which we're
already constructing thank you yes
counselor well this is councillor now
whoever I am
Kedar could I ask for a breakdown of the
affordable housing as it now stands in
total particularly how many of available
at what sort of rent
that's my particular interest I think
the answer to that might be on page 35
in fact council
I think actually we've got the answer to
that on page 35 anyway I beg your pardon
go on yours might be different yes I can
confirm that we are providing for we
were providing for two TT bourbon-glazed
with now increase that's seven and we're
now providing for which is for double
rents we weren't providing any too bad
shared ownership we're now providing for
two as well we are providing for four
one bed flats twelve to bed flats two to
bed houses which and those are all
affordable rented we're providing for
six to bad houses which are shared
ownership we are providing for 12 to
bourbon-glazed as I said previously for
fordable two for shared ownership to
three bed houses four fordable rents T
for shared ownership so we're providing
I've got here 42 all together
it is the same so we're happy with that
thank you hear that sort of the answers
of the question what I was looking for
was to see whether they could tell me
what the breakdown is over the whole of
the hundred and ninety-four but it's
probably not something you've got notes
about this okay question yes here you're
it's good to see more affordable homes
but you're clearly discarding larger
homes to been for that to be able to
deliver those I just wondered if there's
any measure of the economic benefit that
will be so kind is the new configuration
worth more than the old configuration
right and we've actually we found well
sorry and we found there a small market
demand for two and three bed houses as
opposed to the four beds but they're
also it's easier for families people on
the housing ladder to get on two or two
bed two or three bed as opposed to four
bed so we are trying to facilitate that
any further questions thank you very
much if you'd like to return to your
seat thank you for that and don't forget
your notes Thank You councillor Ellen do
you want me to read councillor he burns
memo first or would you like to go first
in true fashion you better Scopus right
as I'm unable to attend the Development
Control Committee please will you accept
this as my ward member this is Rachel
eben comments for planning application
DC 19:01 947 it was part of an outline
application to double one to 15 which
was refused but allowed on appeal the
inspectors appealed condition five
states the development hereby permitted
shall comprise of no more than 175
dwellings this application will
nineteen homes to this taken the total
to 194 which is in convention
contravention of the allowed appeal also
above 190 homes in application for
double O 214 which was also refused on
this basis the application in front of
you should be refused the 19 extra homes
are also within an area of fifty-three
dwellings and not evenly distributed
throughout the site at 175 homes however
if members are minded to approve it I
would ask that they ensure the access to
the north of the site is altered could
you put that up on the screen to help us
the north of the site is altered to
safeguard the mature hedging along
Gipping Road and to improve the safe
access for pedestrians and cyclists
rather than extend the visibility's
display on Gipping Road taking out the
mature hedge for cyclists and
pedestrians to access the road a foot
cycle paths should be extended on the
development side of the hedge through
the marked area woodland belt going
roughly West out of the site mid Suffolk
District Council owns the piece of land
adjacent to the site which in turn
houses a bus shelter on Trinity walk
immediately around the corner from
giving Road
this would allow pedestrians safe access
to the bus stop and pedestrians and
cyclists safe access onto gibing Road as
they would exit Gipping Road just
northwest of the site where there is a
greater visibility if members are minded
to approve the application I would urge
them to include this as a condition
rather than provide ten thousand pounds
to Suffolk County Council to improve
visibility splays by taking out the
mature hedge the conditions should
provide ten thousand pounds to the
parish council directly or via SIL to
provide a foot or cycle path through the
woodland area to connect up to the bus
stop finally I would ask that electric
charging points and not just in homes
with garages but more generally
positions throughout the homes on the
site
separation and the planning officer
would you like to just comment on that
laughs get about the ten thousand pounds
which I don't think is impossible the
recommendation is obviously that ten
thousand pound is goes to the Suffolk
County highways in respect of what is a
recognized improvement for the for the
purposes of Highway Safety I'm trying to
work out the alternative that's being
proposed there it sounds to me like it's
going to require first of all it hasn't
really been explored but ultimately it's
got ownership issues involved here that
we don't know of that includes something
amid Suffolk District Council and now I
appreciate we are mid Suffolk District
Council but we have to deal with
ourselves as if we were a set for owner
to the land so I do not know as a
separate landowner what the intentions
are of mid Suffolk District Council and
whether or not they would accept any
alternatives or changes to their land
and this is not before us so it would be
an unsafe thing to do to go forward on
that basis to the ward member if you
would thank you before I start can I
just respond to the point that the
officer made and that is about this
there's an alternative pedestrian route
it has been explored it would with with
them with law and it would be underneath
the existing electricity cable so it
would not affect the tree planting so if
you know it is it is a goer so to speak
I can only say that he's not before us
and I do not have the owners vehicle in
Suffolk District Council or anybody else
on those land a party to any agreement
at this time so that he's not something
before us to debate as I have it from
the highways authority the options
provided to me are considered acceptable
that's the recommendation from the house
and we just have a comment from the
planning officer I'm more than happy to
pursue those conversations outside the
remit of this application because if
members were to grant permission there
are some conditions here that required
law to come back to us to agree certain
things I'm more than happy to raise that
in discussion in the hope that we can
adapt previously agreed landscaping
scheme but it would be good will from
law and knowledge thought it was a good
idea thank you if you'd like to continue
now right the sites shown in blue black
orange blue black on the drawing on page
20 of the report was the subject of an
application made by Gladman in 2014 for
190 homes that that application was
withdrawn and Gladman made a subsequent
application for 175 homes which was
recommended for refusal by officers
refused by committee that gained
approval VAR an appeal and public
inquiry in the report before you
paragraph 2.3 the officer states that
the conditions placed on that approval
are a significant planning consideration
indeed I hope members have had an
opportunity to study the inspectors
report the most relevant conditions
within the 24 listed in the appeal
decision are the detail shall be in
accordance with illustrative layout
drawing number and they actually quotes
a drawing number 639 one lo3 revision q
so it's got to be generally in
accordance with that layout and the
development shall comprise no more than
175 dwellings these are pretty clear
conditions yet the application seems to
seek to drive a coach and horses through
those two conditions at the appeal
inquiry the applicant repeated time
after time that MIT suffered did not
have a five year land supply was three
point three years at the time and
therefore there were no current
and housing planning policies miss
Suffolk now has a five-year land supply
and the current relevant planning policy
in respect of housing development that
current housing development policy is
the Stowe upland neighborhood plan which
was adopted by this council just six
weeks ago and you can't get much more
current than that within that document
SN policy SNP 14 sets out a design
considerations and in summary states
that development should in every case
result in a development that is in
character with the village and respects
the simple style of domestic style of
domestic architecture in the parish the
report makes it clear that this
application should be judged against
current policies if the application is
to be judged as often to say it should
as a fresh application and not bound by
the inspectors decision it fails this
test the proposed units are not in
character with the village and
respecting the Suffolk simple style of
domestic architecture in the parish so
the application should be refused it's
only now - the proposals in respect of
the pedestrian cyclist crossing on
Gipping Road members here you're clearly
in a no-win situation
the crossing arrangement agreed between
gladwyn and s Suffolk County Council and
set out the inspectors report is unsafe
and now Suffolk County Council
acknowledged that it's on the inside of
a bend at the end of a straight section
of road with high and thick roadside
hedges which need to be protected it was
going to always going to be unsafe and
the partial construction blow of
constructed part of that that crossing
point and the attempted use of the
crossing point have proved it to be
unsafe I can go into more details about
that if you wish so there are three
options in respect to that we can leave
it as it is and hope there are no injury
accidents or fatalities we can destroy a
long length of mature hedge and wildlife
habitat extend the 30-mile limit hope
the traffic slows down to 30 immediately
keep the heads trimmed back and pray
or a safer alternative route through the
landscape well directly to the bus
shelter it's underneath the electricity
cable so there won't be any trees
planted on it and this has been
discussed with ploor this will avoid the
need for anyone to cross twice in order
to get the bus to the bus stop you have
to cross skipping road twice what's a
daft idea when all you got to do is walk
through a hedge or cut that because a
short length of hedge down near the bus
shelter just walk straight through that
route would be safer be more convenient
for pedestrians it'd be less destructive
it'll have less impact on the setting of
the listed Columbine Hall and it would
be safer for cyclists you'd be able to
cycle through that and get onto the get
onto the road where you can see in both
directions if members do feel that
despite everything they are allowed to
allow the extra tele dwellings please
have regard for the increased need for
this direct route through the landscape
belt Suffolk County Council say there is
an increased need for a safer crossing
and it's brought about by the increased
number of dwellings request for an
extension of the 30-mile limit have been
refused by Suffolk County Council so why
are they now saying it's going to be
it's a safe way to here so you can't
guarantee it will be approved floor
homes have agreed to leave a gap through
the landscaping band for the parish
council to provide a direct route to the
bus stop
so why approve a less safe and more
destructive option policy SNP 2 accepts
that 175 homes will be built across
these the two phases of the side this
application to increase the number of
units on phase 2 represents a 19%
increase in a particular area of the
site it's a much more in an increase of
much higher percentage and I don't
accept that that's a small increase the
proposal is less sustainable than the
development refused in 2015 the bus
service has been reduced traffic
conditions have worsened as partly due
to the increase in the number of pupils
at the highest
an increase of 80 percent more than
predicted at the time of the Gladman
permission and there is now a planned
six worn block to accommodate and
further 300 students the new co-op store
which is just open very recently is much
busier than the previous small retail
outlet and this has led to an increase
in traffic on the 1120 the drafted joint
local plan for identifies land for
approaching 600 new dwellings and most
of these are closer to the Stowe market
town center there at the Stowe market
end of the village so the closer to the
town centre they're closer to the rail
station they're closer to the a14 but
these extra the traffic from these extra
dwellings will have to go past I've gone
on the a 1120 pasture schools the
churches and so on so in summary the
housing proposed does not comply with
SNP 14 the number of units is above the
figure in SNP two and in the inspectors
report and the proposal for giving road
is completely unacceptable is safety
landscaping and ecological terms and
probably unachievable thank you for that
councillor just a point on your
neighbourhood plan I believe the policy
SNP 2 so it's approximately 175
dwellings I'm only just quoting it for
clarity yeah I'm just quoting it for
clarity right okay Qwest council
Humphreys whispers thank you
and understand the neighborhood plan
it's just a point correction if some and
you might be able to clarify it it talks
about buildings must be in keeping with
the rule setting of that village is it
not true there are over developments of
a similar style within the village is
still at land therefore does it not
comply
well of course there are some
developments similar to this because
it's part of the other hundred also
houses currently being built
but we've got to keep we've got to
measure it against current policies
those policies were not current at the
time so what the what the parish council
were asking for at the time of the
gladwyn appeal was that there should be
and indeed have asked law was that the
development should have a greater number
of houses that are fully rendered which
is typical of that part of Stowe upland
and and that they should there should be
a palette of different colors to make it
look more like a country so I think I've
read somewhere in the report that it is
a typical urban layout we don't want a
typical urban layout what we want is to
have some empathy with with the area I
think Matheson did you have I'm sure
thank you
yet on on this visibility splay money
and change what effect does that have on
on Heritage screaming etc and Columbine
Hall
the reason the reason that there is a
wider substantial landscaping belt on
the other side of the road is screening
of Columbine Hall and also the the
reason there are bungalows along that
side of the site is that that was a
requirement to keep to screen
the bungalows from Columbine hall but
the Columbine hall is not just a
building is a setting and as you
approach Columbine Hall you do so passed
on the road that goes past this hedge
and it would be wrong in my view to
continue to use that as the prime access
for pedestrians into the site because I
have tried to use it regularly recently
and in order to use it safely a length
of that edge will need to be trimmed
back by about 2 meters and it's less
than 2 meters wide so that means taking
it all out thank you for that right I
think we've come to the point where we
can there to go to it thank you for that
counselor so does anybody want to start
us off with in the debate please cancel
Matheson thank you yeah if just to start
has how does mr. Pierce manage to find
the numbers of bedrooms that I asked
about so I think that's a quite
significant consideration in public
acceptability we can see that this is a
response to the market and again it's
this is all very similar to the
situation 10 years ago sigh Thank You
councillor Matheson on page 35 and page
36 of the agenda it does actually give
you a breakdown of the number of
bedrooms in each
category so for example and perhaps I
should have explained the acronym so I
think members would have found that
helpful if I had done that in the report
but the third row let's say two-bedroom
bungalow
we've got a R which is affordable rent
previously and then we've got affordable
rent that proposal before you so you'll
see that there are originally there were
seven to bed bungalows there are now 12
to bed bungalows so even in that row
alone there has been an increase in to
bed bungalows and by working through
those tables the other acronyms are
affordable rent shared ownership and
then open market so AR s o user food
were in shared occupancy what I've done
in those two columns is compare the
extent reserved matters with the
proposal before you
thank you for that so can we move on to
the debate can someone start us off with
the debate please
we've heard all the speakers no chair to
get things going
whilst I commend the fact that we're
getting more bungalows thanks that's
fantastic it's absolutely one and also
to three-bedroom houses absolute what
one so people can afford to live in
houses of a good standard and that makes
sense but to do that it is add intensity
and it's the density which i think is an
issue I think the density is
inappropriate for this this site and the
fact those previously refused for more
than hundred seventy-five properties and
we're now seeking approval for what
seems to be a hundred ninety four of the
whole site well that goes against the
inspectors comments it also again goes
against our last decision not fire I
don't understand what's changed to allow
us to enable us to vote for approval so
that's my comment on it mr. density I
like houses but the point is what's
changed that allows us to go against
decision previously made and against the
inspectors decision of a maximum of 100
properties I just don't understand it
yeah I mean we haven't actually heard
precisely what I wanted to hear which is
has the number of bedrooms increased or
possibly decreased if the number of
bedrooms is more or less the same and
and we're assured that it's there's
likelihood that we'll sort out the the
the path along along not alongside but
to the bus stop let's say then I can
repeat you know cautiously in favor of
this because as I say the if the if
there is not an intensity of bedrooms
then there isn't really an intensity of
people and probably not even of cars so
you know that to me that is that is
quite important weather officer can
actually give me two numbers for the
bedrooms councillor Matheson I mean I'm
sure he'll work on it as we go through
it but just thinking about it if you've
got a four bedroom house into two
bedrooms that equals four so I don't
know if he's going to work on that basis
so that would be helpful if if he could
calculate that for you yeah but but I'm
just doing it on the back of a flank
paper for the minute but he's going to
do it properly for us I'm sure Castle
Humphries sure thank you as come back on
that point really just because you've
got a four bedroom house doesn't mean
you've got four bedrooms occupied
likewise you've got two bedroom hours
you might only occupy one so actually
working out the figures for vehicles and
density of people it's a bit of a false
and almost impossible sim to calculate
because it's all supposition the fact is
the density is increased at properties
and that's the key point
that's the goal did I see your hand up
or am i encouragement yes and then write
it it's also a my point is also on the
on the increase in density and we heard
the officers say at an earlier point in
response to a question about the
inspectors condition found and
identified that we shouldn't feel
constrained by that as this is a new
application however the inspectors
reason for setting that number on the
site wasn't didn't arise from the
specifics of that earlier application
but a general point as I read it in
terms of stow opulent stove upland it as
a place so about maintaining a
reasonable reasonable density similar to
other parts of Stowe upland so take it
that would have equally apply to this
application thank you
thank you I'm at some risk of just
repeating the same comments I feel you
know normally one would applaud
something which is attempting to adjust
the ratio of houses of particular sizes
to more closely match and needs or the
market demands but as was pointed out
the inspector set on a figure of hundred
and seventy five dwellings and did that
from a consideration of the density in
the area and that it should match a
similar areas in the star plant and this
was a decision noting as we pointed out
more than once we rejected we rejected
the one warranty and rejected the 175
proposals originally so we've rejected
both these proposals before we're now
being asked to increase density in a
relatively small area quite dramatically
and personally I don't think that's
appropriate I do have to say that I do
feel the proposal to change the access
to the bus stop is appropriate but it
seems to be something that could be
achieved in any case we're not arguing
that that should be a clear condition
within this with its approval just a
condition there should be negotiations
to that effect so I think overall I'm
opposed to this convinced just give us a
question before I come to you counselor
- if I may be cheeky Jeff the first is
an answer to councillor Matheson overall
there will be an increase of ten Bates
second second part in terms of density I
just want to try and understand where
we're going with with density and I hear
what the inspector said and I notice the
answer that was given councilor
Humphries to the point you made about
SNP 2 in terms of the character of stow
upland and I think if we can find the
slide that shows that is the character
of this part of stoic and it has been
approved it will be built and there will
be a hundred and seventy five units that
look just like that the piece we're
looking at is right in the heart of this
development it will look exactly the
same as that now when the inspector said
he's limiting it by assuming it could
have been she I think it was he he or
she limited it to 175 they had an
illustrative layout they didn't have the
full details that you have before you
this is a full application so you are
starting again judging judging the
application on the merits as it is
before you and what I have to say is
that when you stand on the application
site and look 360 degrees around you you
will see that you won't see a little
thatched cottage and unloved brick built
cottage you will see 175 houses that
look just like that in terms of what
harm can you identify my suggestion is
that inspector would say you've already
granted permission for 100 units here
you're gonna potentially refuse 119 on
the basis that they don't look like the
rest of Stowe upland
and when the inspector looks around they
will say exactly what you're about to
potentially refuse I can't see that
that's a sustainable reason for refusal
however what I did say earlier and I
just need to reflect back on that the
question of could we get these
away path my initial reaction was it's
outside of this site were strictly
speaking it's outside of the redline but
because it's a full application we can
actually condition land that is in the
blue line and of course the area that
has been referred to is within the blue
line owned by the applicants so we could
actually require that path to be
provided as part of this proposal if
members felt that that would be a
benefit to the village and I I can see
that that would actually be reasonable
in terms of the test of reasonableness
set out by the government thank you
thank you that's very helpful first of
all councillor Carter and then
councillor Matheson can we just have a
fresh input please Thank You councillor
Carter thank you I found myself being a
bit folks originally I wanted to approve
this I thought was brilliant their
breakdown bedrooms would actually be
more suitable to be what is required but
when we go to the density and we are
looking at ten additional bedrooms it
does seem to be like we're listening to
what we need and then trying to add on
and splurge it together socially get
away with adding more ideally what we'd
like to see is being met what we need
without joining the density up without
compressing it to me or he needs which
you just meet what we need and meet the
number of bedrooms we need without the
additional properties it would mean the
loss for some bedrooms but that's what
the area needs is what we ever can deal
with working code brilliance that the
footpath can be conditional because it
should be if we approve that it should
be conditional but the density doesn't
the density isn't correct
we need less density we need it to be
meeting what we need and fewer bedrooms
thank you Thank You councillor Carter if
you're looking for refusal have you got
any reasonable policies that would stand
up against an appeal we've got to sort
of look at that before we sort of say we
don't like things so I hope you're
prepared with that because I think it's
something that needs to be considered
however we haven't got there yet but I'm
just reminding you of your obligations
councillor Matheson and then council
Humphreys again did you want to come
back I think we need to sort of move
this debate on yeah just wanted to
clarify that the you know the ownership
point mr. Paperny did refer a little
while back to it and leave Suffolk
ownership if mr. bass is right then I
you know that including that as as the
condition sounds like very very good
necessary to do
I think the officer just wants to think
about that one for the moment wait in
terms of the ownership so I was reacting
from the ward members comments so they
mentioned that mid Suffolk land was
involved if it's not involved it's
possible to achieve the outcome without
the involvement of a third party in
effect but then I'm satisfied with that
so that's that density is an issue in
terms of a a high density gives you the
impression that there may be harm what
we need to get to in this debate is what
is the harm the fact that we grant 50
dwellings per hectare in other locations
or higher in some cases doesn't
necessarily result in harm and that is
what I need to get to the grips with
here in terms of a robust reason for
refusal if that is where we are heading
I find this case quite unsafe in terms
of where we might be heading if we were
to look at refusal in terms of that we
are dealing with a site within a site of
the same character of housing
too dissimilar in the density and I
don't have any policies that
specifically say I need to restrict that
number of houses I would be suggesting
to the Chairman that we would take this
to referrals should we go down that road
funny you should say that I was thinking
the same thing but having said that yes
yes no please you carry on councillor
Richardson first and then I'm sure
councillor Humphries will come back
after you to have fresh input no chair
so I have a few comments that I'd like
to make about this application firstly
I'd like to echo much of what's been
said already about the increase in
bungalows the increase in the number of
two and three-bedroom houses I'm very
much one of those councillors who likes
to see those sized dwellings
particularly because of new buyers and
the ability to get on the housing love
in the first place I do understand the
concerns about the design and layout and
I would have much preferred if the
original application for 175 was more in
keeping with the villages character but
I think we're now in a position where
we're not dealing with the entire
development we're now looking at a lot
within it and I think it would be I
think a mistake to then try and have
that significantly differ from the rest
of the development I think it makes much
more sense to be consistent and for me
that's that's more important I do accept
that the planning inspectors decision
does have material weight in this but I
think to go back to what some of the
officers have already said it's a case
of although that decision has been made
there has been no harm identified within
what we're discussing today and for that
reason I would be minded to to prove
this application and I don't know
whether this is something which is a
material consideration but something
that I'm just conscious of is I welcome
the fact that this is on a site that is
already under construction because I am
just constant the fact that we as the
council were sort of wrapped on our
knuckles earlier this year after we
failed the housing delivery test so I
think seeing a development that's
already in progress I think it's
actually something I really welcome and
so if I may I'd like to move the debate
on by and proposing that we accept the
officers recommendation
with the condition about the footpath
thank you for that counselor there was a
proposal yes he said proposal propose it
with the additional of the footpath so
do I have a seconder to that please
cancel war boys you're quite happy to
second it well happy you're going to say
and it thank you for that so does anyone
else wish to enter the debate or say
anything I usually come in sorry did you
want to say something else
councillor don't show yeah I think there
is there's policy actually near ppm in
each section one two three it talks
about was not dissipated or existing or
anticipate search of land for meeting
identified housing needs it's especially
important that planning policy decisions
avoid eyes being built at low densities
but we have adequate land we have an
adequate supply therefore surely that's
not a reason for increasing the density
right fair enough
we've heard the debate I I've been
spending one way and the other on this
one because obviously you listen to the
ward member and the ward member is an
important part and knowing him from
previous planning it's always worked
very well thought out and initially when
we were at our briefing I really
absolutely asked what the density of
this was and unfortunately the officer
wasn't there so I am disappointed I also
hear cancer the feels comments that you
know we've had an appeal inspector but
that was on our different and it was
only outline but we've moved on and I
also hear councillor Humphries comments
that it's not in keeping with the area I
also hear the officers comments well it
is now in keeping with the area I beg
your pardon
so much as correction I didn't say that
I asked counsel well him if it was in
keeping with a local with the local area
burn one the river develops that's
agreed with the officer I beg your
pardon I beg your pardon I remain
corrected but I do recall on the whole
of the sites that are on stow upland I
was the chair at the time that refused
it and I said at the time if we wanted
to urbanize
Upland we'd have done it with local
builders and we'd have done it in the
fashion that was suitable to the
community but we've moved on since then
and unfortunately this is a donut bit in
the middle could you just put instead of
on me just put up that little slide with
those those differences the lines on it
if you would please the lines that show
that the difference to what is proposed
and what isn't proposed visually is not
significantly different where we had the
black and the blue lines down whoops
that one so that's an interesting one
and then councillor Matheson obviously
brought up the number of additional
people and effectively we are putting
more people on the site it is a
difficult one I've been writing notes to
myself and going backwards and forwards
and I think if members are minded to
refuse it I would be minded to take it
to referrals committee and then that
might give the officer opportunity to
also investigate further but I think we
can put a condition on regarding the
footpaths so on that basis I have a
proposal and a seconder so all of those
who would like to vote please vote now
in favor of the recommendation with the
addition of the footpath all those in
favor
five and those against three so the
emotion is carried thank you thank you
very much indeed does anybody want a
quick five-minute break that it will be
a quick five-minute break please and
then we must move on we've really got a
very busy case load
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the next
gender point which is item 70 of the
agenda papers my name is Barry Humphries
I'll be chairing this as Cathy as a
board member and parish member nice
stand down and act as the ward member so
be gentle on me it's my first time I'll
try and do my best
without further ado then this is for
planning permission for eight dwellings
in the town of Devlin she on page 275 of
the agenda papers in front of you can
everybody confirm they've had the late
papers as well they've read them thank
you
case officer for this is mr. mark
Russell mark thank you chair good
morning members and ladies and gentlemen
this is a full application for full
application for eight dwellings in
Dedham to the rear of ten Ipswich Road
just for some orientation this is the
site itself it just rode over to the
east I think turning around to the south
you'll see some more photographs in
there to explain the good the greater
context of the site a few listed
buildings nearby but not next to the
site and in the green are the trees
which are protected by order again these
are not relevant to the application
itself here we have the devanam flood
map and as you'll see there is an issue
with the water course that goes through
to Evernham the site itself is just next
to it however outside of any flood
concerns and we've had a comment from
the floods team recommending there being
a scheme works but no objection I should
be able to take you on a video too
okay this is similar to the one that mr.
Pierce shows you the sighted self come
into view now just to give orientation
basically you can see that it's
developed a long it's dish road to the
north is to even rise and just to the
east is cherry close which is a more
recent development just top left corner
there is a bungalow itself which would
be demolished were commissioned to be
granted
okay just blowing out a little bit more
so you can see that the site itself is
on a southern limb of Devon M in the
built-up area boundary but obviously
right on the edge of demonym whether
woodland to the west of great importance
is the development neighborhood plan I
think Devon and correct and same as the
first one in mid Suffolk to do such a
plan certainly one of the earliest and
they're actually renewing at at the
moment there are two sites here which
are near to but not next to our
development site Deb for Deb 3d3 is
looking to take access off ellipse which
road to the right of that you have a
white area which was that woodland we
just looked at and our application site
is the black one this is what things
look like at the moment on the right
hand side you have the the gabled houses
off cherry close and you have the
pathway going up which would be the
access to the site looking out of the
site to the right and I've been asked to
provide one for a bit further out
looking in and that's actually an older
photo but it's just show you where the
road is it's actually before the cherry
close was built but that's where the
road is going towards the access that's
looking out left towards Cherry close
and going up the path we have
relationship to houses the one the left
which is generally unaffected by by the
development where's the one to the right
this will be discuss in a moment you'll
see there a window with the boarding
below it this is going to be discussed a
little bit this would be the window this
it would appear to be the most affected
by the development
looking back down the site towards the
access and then the neighbor to the left
and this is the bungalow itself which is
tabled for removal just moving around
the site it's a lovely big garden bits
and pieces on it
and top here with the potential for
immediate loss were the developed to be
unsympathetic as you can see there are
windows and a garden to add even rice
house now this is one of the key
interfaces of the development with
existing housing cherry tree closed is
to the right you can see the low fence
about 800 millimeters high and the
planting above it you see this in
greater context in just a moment
as you can see further along next to I
believe it's 3 it may be for territory
close that the planting has has been
removed for some reason so it's quite
exposed to the garden this is looking
down into the site so you get some idea
of the drop of land which is something
like 2 meters the planting does
something to secure privacy but
obviously where there is no planting
there is no privacy at the moment this
is in the rear garden of I think this is
number 2 cherry tree closed you're
looking along the garden and if you look
free thank you if you look just to the
right you'll see the coping of the brick
wall which forms the boundary that's the
wall itself now the very roughly because
of the difference in land levels the
land defense itself you cannot see just
see if a she's there there you go so
that's that's the solid solid block
between the two at the moment you've got
the wall which is about roughly about
two meters and then you've got a planted
belt and then you've got the short fence
that we just saw
again I'll tell you the tale and this is
this is the once further stop where the
plantings been cleared and the
conservatory sold see there's a clear
view into the garden and into the
development site okay so here we have
the original layout I draw your
attention to this bit here that's plot
seven and eight with a proposed garage
that's been changed it's at that so if I
just flip back some fortune can see
what's happened the garage has gone the
building itself has been taken away a
couple of meters and angled away more
from the effective properties are cherry
close so that that can be seen as an
improvement on the original plan
visibility's plays how I thought it's
got no objection to this now looking at
the site sections I think the clearest
one to look at is section 2 at the
bottom there that shows you and we'll go
to this more detail in a minute what the
relationship is between the original
houses and the sorry the existing houses
and the proposed you can see the Fallen
land out which is a considerable issue
plot one you can see that the design
reasonably good design overall in my
opinion six and seven now this is the
one to look at very carefully this is
the one that's very close to the
boundary and has been moved away so I
just flip between those you'll see that
that's been the change but actually
they're not scale at the same way that
the one the new one is is actually lower
than the old one okay that's that's the
old one that's a new one
this looks a bit of a mess but there was
a reason for it I'm showing you plot six
and seven the new scheme overlaid on the
old one the original is underneath I do
this makes it clearer so in red you have
what was originally proposed at the
start of this application and it's gone
to that so
it was that it's gone to that so it's
been moved away slightly lower angled
away so further away from the effective
properties that little yellow corner
there is an extra bit that is an extra
effect on immunity but it's a negligible
little amount I've cleared out all the
other stuff so you can see actually what
the relationship would be like so that
that's that's what it would look like
basically sixteen point three meters
between the existing and the proposed
dwellings just to remind you again
having seen all of that what the
relationship is
and again looking up from the gardens
the houses themselves with approximately
seven meters from the boundary okay
the applicant has submitted this drawing
shown a 25 degree line mid Suffolk has
no adopted guidance that's up to date
about amenity issues it's a general
common-sense consideration about whether
we think is acceptable or not the
applicant here is quotable looks like
the BR eak which is their Building
Research Establishment guidance taking a
25 degree line from a midpoint of a
window other guidance may suggest taking
45 in planning sections so it all gets a
bit technical and we it hasn't got
undergone that consideration during this
application this is plot 8 and that also
does create some issues with the
neighboring one Cherry Tree close which
was flagged up earlier just reminder
that's what it looks like at the moment
that's number one and it's similar to
the houses next to it I've overlaid an
image of proposed dwelling which is
notional so the relation should be
something like that it may be I put it a
bit too close but that's what we're
talking about and in particular I'm
looking at some windows which are there
those in my mind are the most effective
ones there are one two other smaller
windows but there is a landing window it
towards 2/3 of the way back which are
flagged up there and another window
below it and that's 3.1 meters from
building to building so where I'll put a
little blue stroke there that's that's
roughly where the windows it's about two
thirds of the way back now typically you
go for a 45 degree line from there and
it's and it's closest that's all I'd say
it's not being measured properly there
is an issue that could be an issue of
the immunity there and the outlook from
that window I will leave it there chair
because I know that there's a lot of
interest in this and it'd be quite a
debate so I'll I'll let it take place
thank you I think
thank you think it's through and well
presented do any of the councillors all
committee members have any questions for
the opposite council Matheson please
yeah I just wanted to clarify the the we
did we through all the late papers this
morning that has the the flood and water
holding objection been being
lifted yes counselor it has Kousaka
three you can ask a question if yourself
can I just have a look at the the site
with the properties on it and can you
tell me what the height of the land is
and the two and a half story buildings
where they're going to be please is it
flat or is it higher than the rest of
the site counsel Kaffee are you thrown
to the ones to the rear the land level
is approximately two meters higher on
the site and is on Cherry close and so
are these two and a half properties
no no polis such lamar's among seven and
eight armed and also on the plans it
says bedrooms three but I can only count
two that's correct
during the amendment those houses were
changed and shrunk down a bit so they
lost they lost a bedroom so I think
that's what happened but certainly there
I'll just check that there are only two
bedrooms in those yeah and can you just
point out them where the two and a half
bedroom our story ones are please yes
sir
it was actually on the plan I know what
they are
it's just on the plan if you could just
show me please a plot plot one is yeah
but two and three are right and I think
yeah and then eight one two three night
one two three yeah well I ate is
actually on the lower part of the site
although the land is rising there as
well yeah thank you you have any more
questions sir children you mentioned the
officer to mention the the windows on
that existing property you mentioned
that first law window was a landing
window the the ground floor window is
water from the letter I received from
the objector and their agent I believe
it to be a kitchen window which means
it's a habitable room so it has to be
considered okay
just a question on slide 12 plots 2 & 3
it says proposed ground floor plan the
second drawing says proposed first floor
plan and the third draw a wing says
proposed first floor plan is that in the
air or two first floors that's like 12
was it
yeah
sorry counselor I edited the
presentation to get some photos in there
so so the numbering is different you're
referring to tell me what it says in our
blog 2000 soom you're correct but we
will check through are there any more
questions for the opposite counsel war
boys
I'm sorry counsel I can't
like my apologies
on page 296 there's a drawing of soca
ways I've just been looking through this
to see where that's been the nature of
the soil has been checked in with
regards to whether circa ways will be
effective in this situation I think the
safest answer there is the the lead
flood authority given their response
saying a scheme must be agreed so that
that's open to a post permission
discharge condition how it's done
whether it's so poised or not so that
would establish later yes before any
well for Nia I think the wording is
prior to commencement of tournaments so
yes up front and I can ask how she feels
question correct yes that was a an error
had been committed that should say so
counselor Carter thank you could we go
back to be slide showing the access to
the probe to the site and the road
sorry couch you said the access to the
site and from the row you need to go in
looking up to be going up to report a
photograph a photograph here please dad
okay could we see again from the road
leading I'm trying to work out the
pedestrian access to the site how would
how would have reach the restaurant
Devlin Road let me see that's going away
from the side obviously are you talking
about this one where is the link to the
path how would a pedestrian get from
these my taxes to the rest of the cities
and the rest of the earth I don't
believe there is a path shown on on the
site so you pedestrians would be at risk
for traffic and issues will change
stopping again at risk of meeting
colliding the road if I made kalsekar
sir it's almost debate so have you got
an actual door I will come back to
debate on that it is important
councillor girl thank you a question
about parking that I understand that
that the plan is short of one visitor
space but looking at the last I'm
looking at what is proposed site layout
on slide six in my pack it looks very
tight and if it's already one visitor
space short I'm not sure that makes it
and compliant with the policy but it
wouldn't take much to completely block
so I put it that's the old layout just
there I think the next slice and you
know
okay so counsel you're asking about
provision of an extra space well it's a
site policy compliant in terms of
parking that's that's question it's got
potential dwelling your answer your
questions about visitor parking you
probably want to have 25 percent
provision so you probably want to
visitor spaces so there's only one that
it's deficient level thank you any other
questions for the officer counsel Matsu
yeah the neighborhood plan could you get
back the the slide there was one slide
near the beginning and presentation
which showed the neighborhood plan I
must say I tempted to download the
neighborhood plan but unfortunately the
technology didn't want to cooperate and
it does oh there was a question there
that are we going to put something from
the neighborhood plan into the pack of
papers now we're starting to move to a
point where we're getting numbers of
applications with village in villages
with neighborhood claims customers in
the south side of there such than it's
been debated over meeting so to answer
your question you'll see an improvement
in the future you've got a question
related to this particular application
in that case counselor Carter I'm sorry
could we go back again to be flood
access I know the site itself is outside
of a floodplain but isn't the range and
entrance and access to it affected five
of lovely
just on you right so I assume this is
that the the most up-to-date devanam
floodplain map and ultimately you are
rights the flood plain does cover the
the road in respect of the frontage of
the sites obviously that's in respect to
the existing situation to a number of
properties along that stretch if you
were to go around the corner you would
also see low road I think it is that
one's long that point is also contained
within the floodplain and of course
that's in front of the e to allocated
sites within the neighborhood plan and
that would be the access point likely to
be that they're put forward for that we
accept that there would be potential
risk in respect of access and egress in
respect to the sites but the flood in
terms of the sequential test of flooding
we are satisfied that the site in its
entirety in respect where the dwellings
are to be placed outside of the
floodplain and out of risk and on that
basis we have we've accepted the
situation as it's okay know the question
so it's like so it's really nice
actually see some of the photographs you
put in there especially the
superimposing of the buildings that
being proposed because I'm pretty sure
it allows us to better understand the
situation which allows to come to a
sensible decision as we move on through
debate without further ado then we'll
have the parish counselor which is mrs.
Dina bed well if you'd like to come up
please thank you mr. bodewell you have
three minutes for him from the start
okay thank you good morning chairman
counselors and offices the Parish
Council held their very attended
very well attended extraordinary meeting
to consider this application the depth
of feeling was such that those who
couldn't attend made sure their written
representations which you and us in our
recommendation for refusal which we hope
you have all read we are referred to the
policies we believe it to be against to
spend six years preparing an excellent
neighborhood
plan to the Encinos policies ignored or
the true impact dismissed would be
unacceptable the offices arguments may
seek to minimize the impact of this
development on our parish but we can
assure you nothing will mitigate our
parishes disappointment with this
planning authority should you move to
its approval an amended version of the
original application was received on
July the 18th and although we can see
that number 5 number 6 and number
Seven's positions have been rearranged
all this achieves is smaller gardens and
a decrease in proximity of dwelling
number 7 to number 3 Cherry Tree close
of two point three meters parking
provision remains inadequate and we
struggled to understand the lack of
objections at a later stage from Suffolk
County Council highways the officers
assertion that this amended plan
addresses the concerns of residential
amenity is outrageous
we hope the review plans would take into
account two major contributing factors
to the objections but they simply
haven't it is also worrying there
although the deadline for comments was
August the 31st the officers
recommendation was published today
before which denotes a total disregard
for all comments received afterwards the
proposed development does not conform to
a number of neighborhood plan policies
particularly db2a which states that the
replacement of existing dwellings and
subdivision of existing residential
plots and gardens must not have an
unacceptable impact on the amenities of
neighboring of occupiers the height
scale and density of the scheme being
located on a high ground that sits above
surrounding properties is unacceptable
the proposal will bridges would result
in a significant loss of residential
amenity for those properties and would
undoubtedly affect residents well-being
we find the officer's comments on page
2a 2.6 for quite staggering in their
insensitivity to the very close
neighbors on Cherry Tree Green
furthermore to say that this is not an
unacceptable outcome in an urban
environment where residential
intensification is anticipated is simply
appalling
Debenham is not urban it is not a town
or a city it is a core service center
yes but it remains a village and one
that wishes to be at ease with itself
we appreciate the need for sustainable
housing and the potential of this site
but were sympathetic size and density
appropriate and access safe development
which this is not the 23 residents who
attended a meeting were strongly against
it as were all voting councillors the
many residents who wrote in to us and
the nine that have written in to you
there is not one letter of support on
your website MIT suffered mid suffered
District Council benefits from a
five-year housing supply summarize I'm
sorry three rates goes really quickly
there is no longer a frantic and often
detrimental needs to always decide in
favor of sustainable development
particularly when the proposed
development goes against so many
policies and the further application of
24 dwellings is already on the pipeline
for a nearby neighborhood plan approved
site really well thank you and how many
of committee members got questions for
the parish councillor though miss
Birdwell thank you we're now hear from
an objector and this time it is mr.
yelman
mr. yeoman good morning and again you
have three minutes it's not long so
thank you after you yeah button on the
right link and in that the planning
officers has recommended it cemented
proposal complete with all its errors
the coping on our wall is not the
boundary it is the fence line is marked
on the developers plan the paw report is
patronizing and dismissive of our
detailed comments the Parish Council and
the neighbourhood plan it fails to
reflect our concerns adequately movement
of plot six and seven by two point three
meters and the deletion of a garage does
not address our amenity concerns plot
eight is outrageous it will negatively
affect one cherry tree by over
shattering the rear garden and blocking
sunlight through the side elevation the
proximity of a nine meter high blank
wall will feel oppressive and enclosing
preventing the resident from enjoying
her amenity a similar proposal I believe
adjacent to 12-bits which road was
turned down about four years ago what
has changed no statute says that every
square inch of space must be covered by
development efficiency does not dictate
so many houses crammed in the parking
and front gardens are inadequate there
are no green at lungs
unlike the houses on its which road
cherry tree close and even rise because
plots two three four and six are all
Road or parking space the Vista will not
soften over time it's concrete it is
ridiculous to contend that this Vista is
better than cherry tree close each has a
garage and the ability to park three
cars if necessary but are surrounded by
good-sized front gardens technical
densities are not important eight
buildings in this small enclosed area
will have a catastrophic effect on our
residential amenity some dwellings are
two and a half stories they may be a
similar height to Cherry Tree close but
they will tower over them because the
site sits two metres higher
this is dismissed saying the landscape
will in absorb them it will not they
will dominate the options of Cherry Tree
close 12 Ipswich Road whose concerns of
windows looking into their garden has
not been addressed either their height
means that windows of plots four five
six and seven will look into the gardens
and rear windows of deben rise their
combined mass will affect rights to
light enjoyed by deben rise residents
since 1997 privacy invaded because the
elevators sight permits direct view down
into the gardens of Cherry Tree close
and an adult is on a direct level to
look straight into our bedroom windows
the report says our outlook will change
but if he's not unacceptable wrong lives
ruined the mental and physical health of
all local residents will be negatively
affected during construction after
completion and of the proposed
development discussion of sustainability
environmental issues of noise pollution
pedestrians etc is inadequate the Human
Rights Act states that a person has the
right to peaceful enjoyment of all their
possessions including their home and
other land it continues that a person
has a substantive right to respect for
their private and family life it's the
open it that can summarize a case the
fast wharf has the apartment
responsibility to uphold the Human
Rights Act and we strongly believe our
rights as stated would be infringed if
this development was approved it's gross
over 2 metalman tall buildings based on
green and not suitable
residential amenities showroom by inch
that's it that's the three urge
rejection that's I'm sorry I have to put
in a bit to correct your office's
incorrect information that's sufficient
that's the end of your lease in 3
minutes that's it yes that's it correct
you you've had you say let's see if
you'd like to leave to see you unless
any others ok fine you many members got
any questions for the objector I've got
one and it's just a point for the
committee and that is obviously there is
no right to light when we come on to
amenity will discuss that load and
debate I just want to make that point
clear thank you for your time there are
no supporters so we're now hear from the
agent which is mr. Smith
please
yep Miss Smith it's the button on the
right believe you have three minutes and
I will allow you to summarize towards
the end of that three minutes thank you
well my name is David Smith I'm the
Regional Director and those with homes
for East Anglia I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank the chairman and
the committee for giving me the
opportunity to speak and present the
scheme on behalf of those at homes from
the outset of our design we have sought
to deliver a scheme that makes efficient
use of the site considers local and
national planning policies and the
aspirations of Debenhams labor plan the
fundamental part of our design brief was
to deliver scheme that as positively to
the character of the area in particular
we made a conscious effort to introduce
a dwelling to the frontage of Ipswich
Road unit 8 that repairs the street
scene of an otherwise uncharacteristic
toothless gap that resulted from the
development of Cherry Tree close the
scale and height of the design of
frontage unit was carefully considered
to respond to the gable fronted forms
prevalent on Cherry Tree close and to
ensure that the variation in roof height
so characteristic of devilment village
was achieved setting its position well
back from the frontage we also want to
ensure that despite the modest slight
difference it would not appear unduly
prominent or dominant in the streets in
relative to the large properties at on
the territory close careful
consideration has also been given to the
neighbors and particularly those living
actually close they've currently lacked
an adequate level of privacy from the
tenant sewage Road our scheme helps to
eliminate the privacy issues that exist
from the window aspects inside the main
living area and from the north and
boundary of the gardens having already
incorporate the improvements that we
discussed during the free application
process a full review of our schemes
performed by the case officer which also
included visits to the site views on how
best to resolve the prevailing concerns
were discussed and ultimately our scheme
was further improved through the
adjustments to the position eaves hi
Andrew form of unit six and seventh this
ensured that the scheme would not have a
none a belief overbearing
or overshadowing effect on the neighbors
the children clothes we are confident
that the proposals bring review today
not only all the technical requirements
but also ensure that the immunity and
enjoyment of the neighboring properties
would not be harmed
we would like to thank the off the case
officer and consult EES working with us
in a collaborative manner and in the
spirit of national policy to deliver
what we believe is a scheme that
successfully responds to the relevant
policies respects our neighbors and the
character of the village we're pleased
to receive a positive recommendation
which reflects a proactive approach
taken we hope the community will feel
able to support the officers
recommendation to approve application
and deliver much needed housing village
with one of the best high schools in
Suffolk we are keen to continue working
with mid suburb and I hope this will be
the first of many successful
applications thank you for your time to
have any questions remaining your
disposal perfect timing and to any of
the committee members have questions for
the aging thank you okay next person to
speak will be the board member which is
councillor Guthrie thank you very much
indeed chair I would point out that I've
only met the applicant and developer for
the first time today but I've met many
residents adjacent to this development
and up and down the village and the
parish council of course I do hope
members who have had the opportunity to
look at them very many well-thought-out
considered responses in particularly
this overshadowing one that came along
and it was very helpful that the officer
put that picture up for us the developer
commissioned a design and access
statement and the author
although trained in such matters has
only alluded to the debenhams
neighbourhood plan and along with the
developers seem to have completely
disregarded it
this report does contain factual errors
for example to point to our affordable
homes kick in that 10 properties I
believe also it states that this area is
noted for potential for allocation it is
not whilst many people have anxieties
regarding doctors schools and
infrastructure and many of those issues
can be mitigated with relevant payments
appropriate departments I have to take
them into account
I know highways are of a great concern
the new exit will in fact make it a five
ways Junction could you just put that
picture up I don't mind not being on the
screen the photograph for the photo a
photograph would be helpful please
it's the one that's sort of coming this
way at all or not if not that will do
for the time being one that shows I
can't remember what you've got a bio
photographs maybe that one will know
yeah that one will do fine and what you
can't see there is where the car is what
I was going to say is that this will put
a five-way Junction on it so the
Junction to the right the road to the
left is the proposed new exit and then
there's a curve of of grass and then
into cherry tree rise stop there please
and so just bear that in mind so it's a
thirty mile an hour stretch of road with
good visibility and the number of
lorries and farm vehicles traveling to
Kenton which is anchors storage turn on
that junction slowly and there is good
visibility however there's no footpath
on this side and to get to the footpath
on the other side which isn't in the
developers remit to sort out the current
problems which is cutting them back in
everything if a footpath is put there on
the left it would have to go through
Cherry Tree Lane to join up or cross
over and Cherry Tree Lane is a privately
owned development and they're privately
owned roads so that wouldn't be a
throughway through for the general
public
turning back to the Debenhams
neighborhood plan together with policy
age 16 and the design and access
statement the development should take
into account the landscape and while
supportive of replacement of existing
dwellings any development should not
unacceptably impact on neighbor amenity
and particularly the landscape you might
like to focus on page two eight to six
point one six point two six point three
as a result of the original plans
towering above the gardens at numbers
two and three Cherry Tree Lane and
further discussions with the applicant
and the planner and my calling request
the garage at plot seven was removed and
car parking put in this space and the
house moved further away and redesigned
roof put in place in an attempt to
mitigate overlooking overshadowing
and permitted development rights have
been removed from these properties it
does alleviate some of the enclosure
aspect of it however if one stands in
bedroom of number three one would expect
to get changed and showered without
meeting the eyeballs of the neighbor who
chooses to look in you might think I'm
exaggerating but because of the
topography of the land the gardens at
plots four and five are approximately
eight point one foot higher than the
patio garden of number three so if you
could put that up please and probably
all the others in Cherry Tree Lane six
and seven going further up the new plots
are slightly lower if you plant trees
the light would be compromised so we
need to stop any hedges and that small
fence that you see is knee-high and that
is the height of the land where people
can then just look over and into the
gardens of these at Cherry Tree Lane
moving to the newly designed houses on
plot six and seven whilst these were
previously of a hip roof design they now
seem to be a conventional route route
roof shape but again attention to detail
the plans of show bedroom three and
we've all
I heard that there is one missing but
it's just a fault I know the residents
of deep and rise are unhappy and there
is an element of an estate tight
location and unfortunately Gardens due
back on to such properties and whilst
Gardens plural behind might have not
have previously been there there was
certainly a garden albeit owned by an
elderly lady so though now would seem to
be overlooking from the properties that
are going to be there however because of
the topography of the land and
previously a bungalow and a large garden
one can see the mileage into referring
to the Debenham neighborhood plan
requesting bungalows which would which
would avoid this overlooking there is
also a mention of parking on the front
gardens but I'm mindful that it is a
consideration and I do know the
inspector at review of the Debenhams
neighborhood plan asked the words that
were the words prevent parking there
would be replaced by resist so we will
resist it and besides there's only one
visit apartments those plots one and two
and three other affected residents at
number 12 its which road plot one for
some reason has been designed as a
three-story dwelling although they tell
us it's two and a half and I come back
to the design and access statement
advising they have read the mm
neighborhood plan specifically say two
states no more than two stories and that
roof accommodation will only be
committed permitted in keeping with the
surroundings again the proposed plot is
higher land and is not keep in keeping
with the surroundings in addition there
will be a large window on the third
floor master bedroom overlooking the
garden of number twelve again plots two
and three design are of a three-story
nature and will impinge on the immediate
e of number twelve its which road and
again not in keeping with the area so we
come to the final plot eight what can I
say the road is a lot narrower than it
looks and the photographs and the
current view of Ipswich Road as one
approaches Debenhams is one of openness
and well-thought-out lead into debin on
the Cherry Tree Lane development has has
setback from their service road with
planting of trees and grasses cars
visiting those properties generally
drive into the driveways of those
properties where you can easily
accommodate three or four cars so
there's no need to park on the front
there the proposals that plot eight is
to squeeze it next to the property of
one Cherry Tree Lane not only blocking
the windows of that property but
enclosing her patio garden into a prison
cell she will have to look out of her
windows to a solid brick wall barely a
meter from her boundary it will block
any morning light into both her house
and garden and render her enjoyment of
the garden impossible whilst the
debonair neighborhood plan accepts
windfall sites and this is one it would
not be unreasonable to put some sort of
development on here but because of the
topography and shape of the site
bungalows and less density irrespective
of the expected density on acreage would
be more appropriate
Debenham and those neighbors would be
more than happy to work with the
developer to achieve a good design and
outcome this application has succeeded
in causing maximum upset when it could
have been so much better I urge members
to refuse this application under the
immunity policy age 16 which was my
reasons for bringing it to committee in
the first place and if they still feel
at a loss I would ask you at least to
come and look at the site and the
topography and all the problems of all
three sets of residents which surround
this site if you don't the neighborhood
clans would have just been a complete
waste of time and mine too Kosuke 3
thank you to committee members have any
questions for the wall member no yeah
councillor Richardson thank you you
referenced the fact that in the
neighbourhood plan I think they've asked
that no two and a half or three storey
houses are built are there only year of
that sort of size in the sort of
immediate vicinity of the development
site Council
thanks Casa Guthrie you said that this
today was the first time you'd met the
developer with such a sensitive site one
might have expected the developer to
have engaged with the parish cats or the
community was there any such engagement
I'm not sure whether there was any
discussion but I do know that I now know
that the developer appeared as a parish
council meeting but nothing was said and
I certainly haven't been approached and
they do actually I think live on-site
again I'm making stuff additions because
I don't know never question is Casa
Caribe Nike immersive off stay there
we've heard from objectives we've heard
from the agents we've heard from the
parish council world member and that's a
time for debate so who'd like to open a
debate that's maths yeah I D when I when
I looked at this I thought yeah yeah
years ago we'd have looked at this and
said oh it's background development
that's not right and chucked it out but
things have moved on quite a bit from
that
and so we've we do see quite a few
things like this now but I think the the
accumulation of unsatisfactory aspects
is is just too too great to accept
really I I think we you know this this
need which we need to work ourselves
into respecting the neighborhood plan as
the most up to date policy in front of
us and the weight that we have to attach
to that I think that we've kind of a
learning curve with that at the moment
but part from the but back then I think
the the high that the height of the
extra two meters of the land and the two
and a half story dwellings which was for
four out of the eight
you know that's not sensitively using
the site in addition I think the this is
a key service center Debenhams it's
sustainable
it's a sustainable location and to them
look at something where unfortunately
that is not safe means of walking to the
business center is incredibly
frustrating that it's not it's not in
front of us whether it's deliverable or
not is another issue I think the the
overlooking and proximity of the plot is
unacceptable and and it was interesting
that the the board member drew
particular attention to the junction has
been created which I I must say you know
hadn't kind of come out in the papers at
all so I think taking all those together
I'm going to put a proposal to refused
on the table now thank you
I need a I need a positive reason for
that for that proposal for refusal yeah
we'll take it now yeah I think I think
the I think the the lack of a
sustainable access into the into the
village center is is one and I think the
housing development cosa message so we
don't lose that point it's an important
point I just like the coming on that
just to give a bit clarity I understand
there was a footpath on the opposite
side of the road I don't know if you've
got if you've got the photos to that
effect but essentially that leads you
right into the village
I appreciate this not a footpath on the
near side in respect to the development
but it's just a crossing in order to get
to that footpath to solely base a reason
for a future on that issue alone would
be exceedingly weak and I don't think in
respectful really would give that much
regard but I'm just giving you that
cautious view given the availability of
the footpath for the opposite side of
the road thank you yes I think what I
have to unfortunately disregard the
junction at the point because it's not
supportive I can't the highways but I
think the the the height the height of
the properties on that on the rising
land I think that that is pretty central
to to the loss of amenity this that's
been produced and and and and similarly
with the plot 8 situation there's an
unreasonable loss of amenity there so I
think those are the reasons that I would
put forward for refusal thank you and
that's quite clear I'm just to pull up
balance and a little bit depth to this
the parish council within a report
actually accepts that some development
could take place on that site I'm
sorry's within their their plan however
they do talk about it being the right
height scale numbers to reduce distress
and neighboring properties which is I
think as your your point yeah so clarity
so the way I understand it is the height
has an issue on amenity especially with
number 8 and it's only 3.1 meters away
from the property at number one cherry
tree so it's a loss of amenity to that
property and actually yeah at the back
and the and also actually a loss of the
property is going to be built there Mina
see wise it's just the same and I think
also property 6 and 7 affects the
amenities of the properties adjacent to
it in cherry tree so it's three
properties that are adversely affected
amenity wise from the height of these
buildings on the elevated position of 2
meters and I think that's an important
point
councillor girl my mistake do we have a
second a councillor Carter yes I second
out on the same reasons that's given I
do again have to say again very
restricted access that maybe just a
crossing but for any one of the
accessibility issues is quite a
dangerous proposition so and also our
second on we have to bear in mind to be
flood restriction again it may be other
properties in it but we focus on the red
line here and not other properties that
have a same issue that's that's quite
important actually the flooded thing is
where it is and a river access and other
roads that go through and we can't
change that those who are looking at a
red line I accept the point you made
about the disability access it's
arguable and I don't know the answers to
that to be honest YouTube web support
that not the valid point counsel Deltans
thank you
I can see that this is a a site which
may be appropriate for the development
and indeed that's recognised within the
demonym neighbourhood plan however this
this scheme kind of challenges one fine
find merit really
and so I plot eight just seems deeply
inappropriate but particularly so
because of its impact on on the other
properties I'm concerned about the lack
of provision for parking given the given
the layout of the given the layout of
the site and it's common to see
congestion and blockage in in diverter
in small developments such as that
they're all see things in in terms of
considering what may be appropriate for
the site I think what has been said by
the parish council and the neighbourhood
plan given the topography seemed seems
right in terms of appropriate for for
for burglars with the with the proposal
as presented I will be voting against
acceptance for the reasons stated thank
you any other debate points caster field
yes I think I do go with the salt that
Pilates has that unacceptable impact on
the amenity of the adjacent building and
certainly doesn't gain very much itself
as terms of amenity for the dwelling it
that is proposed there so that seems
rather shoehorned into the development
I find six and seven clearly they've
been moved somewhat it seems to accept
the point that they present an
acceptable ugly-looking of the gardens
in number two and three and bearing in
mind that the dwelling is a situated on
a two meter high platform so clean
challenges there could perhaps achieve
the right sort of result but the
challenge proposed is not sufficiently
dramatic so I shall certainly be voting
to reject this councillor Richardson
thank you I'm gonna be very brief I
could agree with much of what's already
been said I think but the one additional
point I'd like to make is just to
express my disappointment at the fact
that several aspects of this proposal
contradict what debenhams neighborhood
plan has actually specified so it's not
a site that they've identified they've
explicitly said they want no properties
above two storeys and so I do actual
have a lot of sympathy with the idea of
well if you're gonna go to the trouble
of creating a neighborhood plan what's
the point if if Planning Committee is
just going to ignore it so I and I
completely agree that I think plots six
seven and eight have a significantly
harmful impact on the amenity from the
adjacent properties and so in addition
the two and a half story houses seem to
be out of character with at keeping with
a local character so on that basis I'm
going to propose as well and thank you
and just clarity on that in the in the
local plan that neighborhood plan at
policy 2f it says new dwellings must be
no more than two stories were
accommodation only permitting roof space
was in keeping the surrounding
properties and area which it clearly
isn't
so I think you're right it gives great
weight and therefore it can't be ignored
I'd also like to consider the point of
deben rise actually in effect it has on
that especially plot six and seven I
don't even got any information
what we're waiting for that and
obviously I'm still part of the debate I
agree with most of the comments have
been made its plot a 3.1 meters for
another property it's always their
elevated ground seems a little bit odd
to me plot six and seven that's imposed
and affects the immunity on Cherry Tree
close and it might be also deep and rise
we'll just check that now thanks Jeff
this was considered on site but the one
that I flagged up was the one you can
see there and I got the developer to
change it so there's a side window on
the rear window so they wouldn't be
looking strange their garden and further
along I didn't deem it to be that issue
but then if members are going with a
refusal there is a fuse will be loss of
privacy and loss of lights then things
can be fleshed out so it's not lots of
lights its loss of amenity and the
privacy issues it's beautiful yeah it's
not loss of light because there's no
right to that and I think it's quite
clear in the proposal so without further
ado unless anybody has any other
relevant points to raise we do sorry
will summarize from need for an evening
officer mr. pate G and then we'll go for
a vote so entertain yourselves for a
couple of seconds
no tell so it's not time for debate it's
time yourselves not each other
Thank You mr. cheese
thank you as so obviously I've been
listening to whatever he said and I've
obviously taken a lead from the proposer
of the motion to refuse the application
if I may suggest that this would be
approximately the refusal that we'd be
talking about the development if
approved would result in significant
loss of amenity and light and would be
overbearing intrusive impact from plot
eight to number one Cherry Tree close in
addition the developments of plot 1 to 7
would be overbearing with moonlighting
overbearing and harm amenity to the
residents of Tralee Cherry Tree close I
don't know if you want to include deben
rise as well in that context are given
the height of the development on the top
customer Senor comment yeah I'm not a
little bit more I think the the other
the other reason that I think mr.
pikemen she might might consider is the
is the conflict with the neighborhood
plan which well let me come to that so
I'll leave demon rise off for a second
and then we move on to saying that
therefore in conclusion it's contrary to
the local plan policy age 16 GP 1 a tree
and the neighbourhood policy
neighborhood plan policy Deb - which
talks about appropriate housing and that
picks up on the amenity issues of new
housing if you want to add other reasons
- refusal the conversations have been
around the design of the properties
being above two-story that is in
conflict perhaps in your view - Deb - of
the neighborhood plan but I would
separate that as a separate reason for a
refusal because we're talking about a
design aspect and whether it's in
keeping with the area and a further
consideration that people have been
making has been the sufficient parking
issue
now I've just had a quick look at the
Suffolk advise weak parking standards
and it is correct in terms of the
development of this size should have two
visitor spaces we only have one visitor
space I will say that's a fairly if it
if it was the only reason for refuse all
that's a fairly weak but it in
conjunction with others there is a point
to make that the visitor parking could
be picked up as being out of so a
contrary to the Suffolk advisory
guidance and would risk poor parking to
the character and amenity of the area if
you wish to add any of those please
listen it is actually in conflict with
with county standards speaker they did
they not pick that up anywhere and I'm
struggling unfortunately to find a plan
which tells me which which place is
which and I've been quite got my head
round that the geography of Dedham this
I I can't really comment on whether we
should be including both closes in in
the amenity loss we're getting a map up
but it's the road just in the north
you just get a sense of a bit of demon
rice there actually you can see the
chimney to one of the houses thank you
so this is plot eight roughly looking
north
d be close to the north castle
north-northwest
so in respect of deben rise you've got
two properties almost three properties
that boundary the north side of the
proposed site and it their proximity to
this site is similar to Cherry Tree
close
although the proximity of Heights is
somewhat different you obviously have
the Cherry Tree close that of a lot
lower and even Rises isn't essentially
I'm guessing on the same plateau but in
terms of the two and a half story and
you're overlooking harm issues given the
orientation of plots one two seven they
would actually have potentially more
impact on to even rise in some
circumstances than cherry tree given the
orientation of the buildings
so in effect you if you're if I was to
Superman for the layout on top you've
got because of the way the orientation
of the proposed properties are would
their windows are kind of fully more
directly overlook the deben rise
properties but the overbearing nature of
the of the heights of the buildings
would probably have more in effect on
the Cherry Tree close because they're
lower so you've got two different types
of amenity issues being played out
between the North and the east boundary
so sorry I think well I think it sounds
if we should we if they are also
slightly different in in the way you
describe them we probably should include
both of both of those points on an
amenity
I mean I'm conscious of that we're
always encouraged to not not throw that
the whole you know baby in the bath or
babies above what we you know not to
throw too many different things at it I
mean only the strong cases and strong
arguments but as it's all supporting the
same point of amenity then perhaps we
should just do a final summary and then
we're going to go through the vote so
from from what we're saying I we're not
picking up on the design aspect of the
two-story properties that's been all
right
well I picked up the amenity of the
heights of the buildings so the heights
of the building causing the harm so I
picked it up in that context the name
the neighborhood plan specifically says
only wants to story with rooms in the
roof wherever it is in keeping with the
area and by in keeping I'm assuming that
means in keeping with the design aspects
of that particular locality so I'm
assuming I'm not going down there we're
just dealing with the amenity of the
height of the buildings okay right so
that's gone so in effect I am just left
then with are we are we gonna include
the visitor parking all right you know
what you'll need your second or two or
confirm this as well obviously no Sekar
okay thank you so on that basis and you
may need to officially do this but the
development if approved would result in
the significant loss of amenity by light
reduction over barring an intrusive
impact from plot eight - number one -
Ettore close in addition would be
overbearing and harm amenity from plots
one to seven to the residents of Cherry
Tree close and even rise and country to
local plan H 16g p1h free and Debenhams
neighborhood policy - furthermore within
second reason would be development fails
to provide sufficient visitor parking at
advised by the Suffolk advisory guidance
and would risk poor parking and risk to
the character and amenity of the area
and that would pick up on policy T 10
they put this down and Devlin policy
number seven thank you thank you so do
have proposed if do you have a second if
a refusal based on all the policy
statements and the conditions that we've
actually just discussed therefore we
will go to the votes kalsekar yeah we
knew our second yeah got that okay so we
are going to go to the vote for refusal
for all the reasons stated body officer
in a summary so we're really happy those
conditions those in favor refusal
anonymous refuse
right I think we're all ready to go
we've got a really big further thing to
do so can we move on to the next item
please
which is is Liam so showing we've got
your delectation snow after we go thank
you
if I can just draw your attention to the
fact that Planning Commission has
previously been granted on this site
this application is just to vary the
approved plans and drawings so that the
principal and general considerations of
this application are restricted to the
scope of the alterations they're
summarized on page 1 1 3 if we're in the
right order where the agent has
submitted a summary of the planning
changes and that's a useful summary of
the alterations if I can just draw your
attention to the fact that house type 1
4 5 6 which in your papers talks about
alterations to the headers to the
windows that in fact is not now taking
place over all the as I said the
alterations are detailed on that
planning changes summary which is quite
a useful reference point so if we just
go through the slides the site is in
Gillingham located to the west of the a
140 sure you know we're getting them is
and the application site is hatched in
pink to the east of the village the
parish churches to the northwest of the
site and you'll see two public footpaths
crossing the site and the little green
circle towards the eastern boundary is a
tree protected by a tree preservation
order this is the overall block plan
showing the layout as far as the
proposal is concerned there is an
alteration to the width of the public
footpath which runs along this northern
boundary here and a slight associated
increase in the depth of Gardens so that
the public footpath is 2.5 metres wide
which is quite adequate for for such a
provision
again we've got some block plans which
show the relevant house types each house
in this application is now proposed to
be fitted with an air source heat pump
in various locations they are shown to
the rear or the side of the properties
comments on Environmental Health Officer
refer to that propose that aspect of the
proposal so this is just going through
through the layouts indicating the
different house types the comments
relating more specifically to the air
source heat pumps are for these
dwellings here and the mitigation
measures that were identified in the
submission have now been incorporated
such that the sound levels should now be
acceptable this again just shows the
footpath to the northwest of the site
surrounding development the street
elevations which summarize the
alterations and summarized on this slide
and then I think I barely need to to go
through the elevations really that the
summary of changes does indicate that
some of the house types are having false
chimneys removed others there are slight
alterations to the fenestration so this
is as proposed this elevation shows
splayed chimney here
so these are V elevations as proposed I
do have some photographs coming up which
will show that some of the houses are
under construction to give you an idea
of the alterations that are part of this
application the garages for example some
of the garage doors are removed from the
side elevation such that they're now
both on the rear elevation the nature of
this application is a fairly minor
amendments that's the summary of changes
it's difficult to read there but members
have got that in their papers so this is
the the footpath the gravel paving here
has been put down it's quite near the
marketing suite so it's it's not a this
isn't the final arrangement these are
the rear fences to the the dwellings
adjacent to the site so this is not the
final width but the width proposed is
two and a half meters which is probably
more or less what that is at the moment
and moving slightly further down the
site you can see dwellings under
construction
this slide just shows where the splayed
chimney is proposed as one of the
alterations on this house type
previously there were a little leaded
window detail above these windows that's
now been removed these are the splayed
window heads which were proposed to be
altered but are now being kept as
constructed
false chimney removed from that house
time
this shows the alteration to every front
door as approved it had a square rather
than a diamond pane so it's a very small
detail and there's an alteration to the
brickwork around the the front door on
this particular house type this is
actually show the show house at the
moment and the fencing here has been
repositioned to accommodate the air
source heat pump finial has been removed
from the porch there was a finial
hanging down above the front door source
heat pump so that's the standard type
for each dwelling but on that particular
dwelling it's on the side elevation very
small alterations to window positions
and rain water pipes this is the
marketing suite which would have
standard double garage doors when it no
longer serves this particular purpose
and to the rear you can see that there
would also be a garage door in that sort
of personnel door in that location and
the door type shown there is now what is
proposed for the rear of each dwelling
it was previously
boarded door
so in a summary there's little to take
into consideration it's it's minor
alterations it's brought to two members
because the permission is for more than
five dwellings so it's a major
application in those terms
although considerations are of a mind
and nature the Parish Council raised a
question of surface water disposal and
flooding on the site you will see in the
terms the planning history that various
conditions have been discharged and that
includes a surface water scheme and the
development needs to be carried out in
accordance with that approved scheme so
at this stage it's it's either a matter
perhaps for enforcement to look into or
it may be that as the scheme is still
under construction they haven't put all
the surface water drainage in but that's
not for consideration as part of this
application the on the front page the
recommendation
I apologize didn't get completed
properly but the recommendation on the
front page should have had various
sections deleted such that its grant
permission with conditions which is as
identified in the conclusion any
outstanding conditions from the previous
permission would be carried forward but
in fact all the conditions have been
discharged so it's just a case of
reiterating that those approved
conditions where necessary should be
carried out in accordance with the
approval so the recommendation is to
grant permission with those conditions
as appropriate thank you for that just
before we go on why what's this all
altered I missed something
I think it's just various design details
as development has taken place they have
altered some scheme some some aspects as
part of a non-material amendment
previously they wanted to put air source
heat pumps in I think it's just the way
that the designers evolved during
construction and demand okay thank you
does anyone else have any questions
councillor gold and then cancer just a
question about on page 83 about the size
of the affordable homes was a comment
from strategic housing that the
affordable homes are not up to standard
being 2.6 square meters too small
there's an officer comment about the
affordable dwellings am i under
construction associate association with
all--but housing I just wanted a view on
on whether there was an issue here or
not
essentially the housing officer is
referring to the national space
standards I suspect and ultimately this
doesn't comply with those but we
approved it previously not complying
with those what we've got in front of us
at the moment
is effectively a list of cosmetic
changes to the external appearances of
the buildings the additional of heat
source pump air source heat pumps and
some strike mine and layout changes from
respect at the footpath because of the
the the plants and the the slight layout
changes we wouldn't normally put this
through as an or material amendment but
most of the cosmetic changes we probably
would have done if it was just those
unfortunate because of the nature of the
application is a major application
that's why it's before you but
effectively it really is just those
minor changes that we're dealing with at
this stage it would be unreasonable in
your office's opinion to try and now go
back on the sizes of the properties
given the extent permission that's
already being built
and you throw the questions counselor
field just a brief run about the heat
pumps somewhat surprised that they're
noisy I wonder what the noise levels are
now that because you refer to some
tables but you haven't published them in
any way and what sort of noise reduction
and they providing is it sort of fences
around them or would yes as the the
technical report which was submitted
recommended that there should be fences
around some of the air source heat pumps
whether at the noisiest and they are now
they have now been included as part of
the application so the reduction is now
at acceptable levels and they need to be
conditioned that they would retain
provide and retain the screen fences
that make the noise levels acceptable do
we know what those noise levels are just
for interest
just while the officers looking for that
it would be acoustic fencing they put
round not just the little stuff well
it's described as a closed boarded
timber fence whether that's acoustic
fencing I think it's just just that a
Coast boarded fence is that yeah yeah
yeah I haven't got the whole I haven't
got the whole table of calculations but
they are it is now in accordance with
the the committee development standards
okay any further questions if not I
think we can sort of move on swiftly
does anybody want to start the debate on
this one
oh sorry forgot the world map but I'm
trying to move on and move and I do beg
your pardon I'm so sorry my
understanding of this is that it is
cosmetic changes the there appear to be
satisfactory measures in hands to
control the noise mitigation measures
though one point which was made by
kissing a parish council was not
strictly relevant to this planning
application is about the adequate and
permanent provision to prevent surface
water
my understanding is now thanks to the
planning officer that the surface water
scheme has been submitted and approved
and its enforcement will be by mid
Suffolk District Council
does anyone have any questions shall we
try and counselor Richardson first and
then no it wasn't questions you were
just moving on swiftly questions yes on
that that point just made I mean I'd
picked up was in the parish council the
surface water and so on
I thought the the what they were trying
to find out was the you know there was
this conflict on page 100 and was it I
saw it 83 when the county and the
Environment Agency were sort of both not
taking responsibility essentially and so
it's the same in Suffolk that
responsible for enforcing it I don't
think that's what they were that was
what was concerning was it was which
flood or authority was taking
responsibility for this being right the
the we as a district authority in
respect of the conditions that we impose
are the enforces of those conditions so
therefore if the construction of the
sustainable drainage is not in
accordance for the plans that we have
approved then we would be looking to
enforce that and if they're breaching
that condition we would have to get them
to resolve that point the problem here
which I suspect the parish is picking up
on we're in the middle of a site being
constructed so whether all elements of
the sustainable urban drainage have been
put in place for it to work efficiency
efficiently or not I'm getting is in the
middle of a transitional moment we will
then allow if need be the problem
results and we can be proven is part of
this sustainable drainage system we'll
look for our enforcement team to take
that further with consultation of our
flood team because obviously they are
the experts in what works and what
doesn't and we'll take that forward on
that basis but we are the ear forces on
planning conditions in that respect all
right so I think we're now into debate
please I saw you did it again together I
think with hob councillor Richardson
first thank you I mean I only just
a couple of comments there on the basis
that we're looking at some very minor
cosmetic changes which don't deviate
significantly from the original planning
application then I'm just gonna go
straight forward with the proposal that
we accept the offices recommendations
and then counselor Humphreys no chair
simply to second the proposal thank you
very much will unless anybody
particularly wants to speak I think
we've had a good reason for it before is
I have a proposal a seconder all those
in favor please vote and we are
unanimous and thank you very much cancer
world boys you can join us back again
there thank you so we're now on to
actually it's the mark Russell act for
this today isn't it yeah so you the
floor is yours for page 1 3 3 2 2 1 oh
the Brahimi contractors limited
application thank you thank you sure you
say Brahimi I so for any I don't know
but absolutely anyways it's floored and
wrote greeting members may recall a
hybrid permission from actually somebody
might not because about three years ago
when it came to committee an application
for full permission for a training
facility at the engineering company and
outline for 52 dwellings so what you
have before you today is the second of
those just to remind you where the site
is it's in the parish of creating sent
Mary but actually not very close to it
if I come out a little bit you'll see
the flood map there and actually we seen
even market in a minute over to the left
give you some indication where it is so
neither markets just over to the left
the south west there and criticism a
proper is over to the north but but
quite some distance the permission was
given on the basis that the local the
employer would stay local with his
training facility so that was that was
how that was all done back in 2015
so it's a southern end of this so wait
southern in Rowlett is where the
training facility is the north end which
has got bits and pieces on it there on
this historic map is now tabled for
housing this is the entrance and
basically it's gonna be the same
entrance for the houses as it is for the
the training facility we'll see in a
minute just going up and down the floor
and Road you get a picture for it and
one or two of my library photographs
were lost self had to rely on Google for
this but I assure you this is what it
still looks like a little net okay so to
the proposal itself so the buildings on
the red are those relating to the
engineering side of of the company
that's brainy brainy rohini over on the
right the the training facility we were
talking about is the one up at the top
right there up in the north east of the
site now it's going to explain and I've
made this clear to the chair already
there was a slight glitch in one of the
plans if you notice to the south he's
just here that was really where the open
space sorry that is where the open space
are going to be that's where it was
going to be it's just here so it's
changed that's been the one change which
wasn't reported but it makes it makes
little difference to anything it's just
to make you worth it that's the first of
all plan again same thing there and the
roof plan basically so that's the lie
layout I'll show you some of the
drawings that's that's the proposed
boundary treatment
and that this is what they look like and
there's a there's a pallet of houses
there's there's there's lots of slides
here and they'll be nice not to show too
many because you get a good flavor for
the first few what we're looking at here
and it's a good honest fresh palette of
design forms that traditional in many
ways but a lot cleaner as well and
uncluttered with chimneys and bits and
pieces like that so in a nutshell as I
speak um as well spin through them the
proposal it's one of those rare sites
which doesn't really excite any
immediate interest because it's not
really got much in the way of neighbors
what it does have are issues which are
ongoing about sewage possible flood
issues and that's pretty much it now the
flood issue strangely enough is actually
part of a condition relating to the
outline permission which I'm still in
discussion with the floods team about
the last conversation I had with a
reasonably happy but I just want the
sign-off for that for that condition so
I can just say everything's Jake if it
isn't then they've got to come back with
another layout so it's in their interest
to make sure they do that properly and
apart from that chair it's fairly
straightforward it's 52 dwellings as
already allowed to outline and I'll
leave you there before I go to questions
can you just confirm that this will if
you'll excuse the pun wash its own face
from sewerage and flooding and it will
not add to the current problem which is
outside this red line plan that's the
important section can you confirm that
there is an existing problem which has
been flagged up by a neighbor which
we're aware of which it's not the
obligation of the applicant to sort out
but we want comfort from the sewage and
the water provider that it won't make it
any worse if there's any indication it
will then we can't discharge that
condition and they can't build it out
discharge it yes yeah well that's what I
just want clarity for because clearly
you know the developer can't sort out a
problem that's ongoing but if it makes
it
then we don't want to do that thank you
questions any further questions
counselor
oh sure thank you just a might missed it
I'm sorry for their no carts didn't
report affordable housing and what's the
percentage if any that was all done at
outline so I can I can dig out to figure
for you but it's it's not for here it's
already been decided out okay sorry yeah
any further questions yes sorry
counselor field yes page or slide
knowing that suppose one live one
I was just bit unclear about the
acoustic fencing or whatever that's
proposed on the I 14 which is just over
the back he's moderately noisy I believe
and this plan left me in some doubt as
to what was being proposed so whether it
could be explained in the detail yes
slope one fifty one has got details of
the acoustic fencing I think your your
question is probably where's it going to
go is it gonna be somewhere it's gonna
do something I'm just gonna check the
outline permissions I think it's all
covered in that one people I don't quite
remember I debated yeah
well it's what they says red brick wall
and it's got a grid line and it says
closed boarded fence and that's a black
line and then there's a green line that
says new retaining wall system wasn't
quite sure whether I really understood
would it be fair to say mark that there
are three aspects of the acoustics
this is another one those conditions
from outline so condition 21 of outline
says basic details of the attenuation
bunt acoustic bear etcetera needs to be
submitted so again we've got it here
we've got some indication what it is but
it's part of a submission of of the
condition it's possible that we say yes
the outline of something prop something
conditions that they're a bit stuck good
enough to come back and do another round
so if I may just draw members attention
to page 151 ultimately what you've got
is a development that is cut into the
site so you have a retaining wall along
the northern boundary of the split and
also eastern boundary of the site and
that obviously is in a correspondence
where the the main road is you then have
I'm retained trees and other bits and
pieces within that before you then have
a series of fencing that's part of this
Bund
that's proposed I would probably suggest
to you that that's quite significant in
respect of possible barriers to noise
certainly more significant than most
along though market councillor
Richardson thank you just head up
apologies if I missed this but I've just
done reading on page 139 under design
and layout paragraph 5.9 it says some of
the dwellings up on glaze but most a
2-story do we know exactly what the
breakdown is between the number of
different story houses
I'm sorry chair I didn't catch all of
what you said my hearings not too good
it's not your fault could I just repeat
Emma this might be something further
that was done an outline so apologies if
that is the case but I just wanted to
know if there's a breakdown of the
number of bungalows versus two-story
properties because it makes reference to
their being summer bungalows but doesn't
give an exact figure I mean the short
answer is yes it's there somewhere the
longer answers I'll take it out for you
right so he will look that one up cancer
Matheson work and we just let the
officer just answer that question first
sorry I mean I presume it's a question
so he's busy he's busy doing something
at the moment
perhaps when we come to the applicant
maybe they might have the answer to that
and while we're sort of going forward on
it is the applicant here yeah in the
moment we'll ask you the question sorry
yes go on then I think we can ask that
can't we him yes
yeah six bungalows thank you yeah that's
all right it's just the will come to you
in a minute it was just a number of the
question was asked six bungalows
councilman yeah the the yeah I was on
the committee three years ago I remember
this one the other the other thing at
that time with the part from the sewage
foul water problem to be sorted out was
the the ability to walk safely into
Needham and I wondered where we were
with with that that requirement from the
Lyon stage also a condition it was
heavily conditioned so again what brainy
have done and it's been a job of work
they've discharged all the conditions
for the training facility that's done
but they've been also discharging those
for the outlying permission for the
housing and we're in the middle of
discharging those norm discussion so
they still have that's an obligation on
their part they do have to provide the
foot way and that's part of the
conditions of the outline element so
it's under discussion yeah I think what
I'm asking that's not part of this
discussion because this is that must
reserve matters this is a reserved
matters application so you're you're
dealing with this site in terms of
layout and design and appearances on
unfortunately that off-site issue is
controlled by a planned condition under
the outline application so in respect of
debate and consideration it really isn't
the place for here on that one right so
there we are
so you throw the questions now right
good then we move on to travesty from
Mohini because we don't have the parish
council objector or supporter so if you
would now like to come forward please do
so good afternoon chair chairperson
Torrey and councillors I'm travesti from
the management director of Rohini civil
engineering as you aware this is the
detail part of an original outline
permission that we've already got so a
lot of the questions you've been asking
have already been dealt with and as mark
explained we're discharging those as
part of the process obviously I'm
pleased see that the Planning Department
of recommended the application for
approval but they was just done I just
wanted to address one of the issues
which was raised earlier and there and
was one of the objections raised by well
the only objection I think from a
neighbor was the issue with the flood
and we are aware that it's a historic
issue Anglin water have already done
some work to alleviate that problem but
and they have confirmed that there is
capacity in the existing system to cope
with the the additional properties we're
proposing put on here but as a good
neighbor what our intention is to do
some more improvement works downstream
to improve the situation that that would
need to be done with the agreement of
angling water so that's you know we
can't guarantee but that is our
intention we've been in discussions with
the neighbor and the adjoining property
owner you know it's perfectly feasible
but need to be done with agreement of
angling water that's it
any other questions
thank you very much does anyone like
councillor Richardson please yes thank
you very much so just off the back of
the previous question about the number
of bungalows could you give us any sort
of statistics about the breakdown of
sort of two three and four-bedroom
blocks I can't remember with exact
details but there is a mix of there's a
few four four bedrooms I'd say probably
six all right four bedrooms got a number
of threes and twos a mixer and the guy
in there there open market and
affordable affordable element is
actually 33% question but the majority
is probably is two and three-bedroom
houses on there and there's a few
affordable flats it's a real good
mixture different house times and I just
interject on there I mean we have got a
list of them here but it's so small we
can hardly read them yeah can you put it
on the screen and then enlarge it I mean
technology can help it sometimes but to
be fair if this is it you know the
application we really need the details
but perhaps we could reach an attempted
to trim out the development of the
presentation I took that one out so
we've got it here but it's in micro font
we can do some calculations before you
possibly go the numbers haven't changed
since the old line no which was approved
casler feel do you have a question yes
just can I go to the flooding and
drainage thing the paragraph 8.2 and
points out that the cadet certain
conditions were discharged in March and
there were a whiting confirmation that
the housing element of the surface water
drainage strategy was approved or was
now satisfactory it says it will be
reported in the light papers which I
didn't notice and it will be dealt with
by condition who are gonna be an
integral part of the application
and the conditions have there 1 2 3 4
conditions
neither none of which refers to surface
water drainage I understand
sorry counts that was poorly worded
wasn't it the outline that the full
element has been discharged the outline
as in the housing element remains to be
discharged
still I'm discussions with him I think
we're pretty much there so that was why
it was gonna be reporting the lake
papers but it's not quite ready to be so
and the conditioning question reverts
back to it was an outline condition so
that was it was loosely worded just to
confuse you sorry any further questions
yes council war boys please this is some
extensive analysis of your proposal by
Suffolk Constabulary yes what's notice
that never seen that and it's
recommended that you seek secured by
design National Building of Google this
first time I've seen that actual report
from the Suffolk Constabulary obviously
passed on to the architects and see if
they can accommodate it um it seems like
it's decisions of Windows and and some
of these stuff that we can probably
accommodate I can't say we accommodate
everything but that's I'll pass on the
architects and see if they can
incorporate it into the design if you'd
like to press the button often return to
see and very much indeed I just have a
paper from Council and Norris I don't
have anything from Council of Stephen
Phillips but councillor noises said
Gendron unable to attend the meeting on
witness take please accept this evening
as my comments as board member last I
appreciate that this application is in
respect of reserved matters relating to
add line application for one double 8:15
which was granted permission on the 8th
of the 416 and therefore the principle
of development has been established I
have two primary concern
it's namely foul water and surface water
disposal the angular water consultation
on pages one through five monthly six of
the papers appears to be the nature of a
qualified response I would prefer to see
their recommendations clarified and
highlighted within the conditions on
page one fall on paragraph two ten
particularly with regard to the sewerage
problems reported by a resident on page
136 under item B representations
connectivity Florida Road is quite
narrow winding with a few footpaths
along its length paragraph four three on
page one through eight states in wider
highway terms of footpath linking the
site formed part of the Planning
Commission for one double eighth and
Haskin as condition ten prior to the
commencement of development of a scheme
including a timetable for the provision
and adoption of a footway shall be
submitted to and agreed in writing by
the local planning authority the
submission of these details will need to
be agreed by condition before any work
and commences on the housing phase end I
would suggest that this needs to be
reiterated in the conditions listed on
page one four one with the
recommendation well we've already
covered the sewerage aspect of it yes
yeah group of that chairs another one
those it's in the outline but another
one those things we've been trying to
sort out under condition so you know to
make council Norris the content it's
being treated seriously we could put
informative reminding the applicant of
those matters
and we've got some figures for you here
thank you Robert better eyesight than
mine it's it's the market housing is
nine times three betters nine times for
better six times five betters and the
affordable four times two we're into
debate on this one who'd like to start
something no chair thank you so it's a
brownfield site the MPP Fe says we give
it real weight which we're going to I'm
sure to develop this particular site I
think the design looks good the house is
a fair mix there people might put their
hackles up at 33% or 35% affordable
housing but course the MPF allows this
brownfield sites I think that 3% is
pretty good given this site and
constraints flooding has been dealt with
by conditions and surface water I can't
find any reason to not approve this and
I'm minded for approval is that your
recommend to move things along
I propose approval as they'd done before
you with the conditioning note that you
just mentioned thank you second thank
you very much wish to speak at all - no
thank you does anyone else wish to speak
on it cancer medicine yeah I mean as I
said I was I was there at the time so to
speak and you know it is it's concerning
that the the the particular issues of
the sewage and the and the footpath
access to Needham was which was so
fundamental to to the original
discussion and decision and all right
they were put on there as conditions but
three years later the the job comes back
to the committee with the reserve
matters with those things still not
actually sorted out and I you know I
find that a bit a bit worrying I mean I
accept that yes the conditions are still
there and will remind them through
informative but it does suggest a rather
difficult
to achieve so it's a pity it's in front
of us without them without the solutions
I've been asked to comment on that and
ultimately though if when we place
conditions on outline we do actually try
to avoid it as much as we can but we
have to if we are looking and concerned
about the timing of aspects we can put
concurrent with reserved matters so
therefore those details do have to be
considered before or at the same time as
the reserved matters application in
fairness in this case that is not as I
understand it the case and so we have to
judge it in our narrow we have to keep
to the focus of this application which
for what it is which is just the the
layout appearance and so forth yeah
thank thank you noted yummy perhaps
we'll keep that one in mind for the
department and concurrent good words yes
counselor feel I guess on this issue
there were two things that were of great
concern I think at the outline stage and
my views they were the acoustic fencing
the ensuring that residents don't suffer
hide noise levels from the I 14 which
I'm here from a distance of a mile and a
half so a few hundred yards or a couple
hundred yards is probably quite
significant there were four cautions put
in and I note there on these column
planks so that seems reasonably
acceptable the other one was the the
issue of sewer join as accounts or
elsewhere I've had to get Environment
Agency to bully Anglian water into doing
things I do take the applicants comments
that they're as good neighbors going to
do what they can and I guess there is no
option but to put trust in yeah
in that way so with those reservations I
think I'm happy to support this
recommendation yeah well I've got a
proposal in a second or so if we don't
need to labor the point on this anymore
all those in favor please vote and those
against
shall we take the vote again right all
those in favor of the recommendation
please vote we are you know yes thank
you
we can resume now so we're all back
thank you very much indeed so we'll go
to the last case today thank you
on page two double one and it's mark
again Thank You chair hello everybody
good afternoon now the last item you
have before you is outline housing
application for 28 dwellings
on Lex Lord Road in Stratford it's a
wedge of land here
this is allocated in the Stradbroke
local and they've got plan as well in
terms of any constraints there are few I
would however draw your attention to the
listed building just here and that is
referred to in the consultation response
from Heritage coming up in a moment just
to give you a orientation of what we're
talking about that the housing to the
Left row to the south and to the north
west are allotments I've drafted in
there roughly where the access is going
and just to clarify at this point this
is an outline permission application and
only access is sort of this pointer just
give some orientation sites on the left
and you can see already there's a foot
way which is the other side of the trees
which is used and will be linked through
from the site the indicative site layout
has been submitted but be reminded of
course that is only access that is going
to be given permission today if you do
indeed grant permission
just blowing out of it more to give you
some more indication about what it looks
like and the again it's it's indicative
because it's an outline application but
these are the drawings that the
applicant is submitted
well that was it okay there haven't
there have been there's been a little
bit of attention to it but but generally
the struggle has been support or it
because it isn't the neighbourhood plan
so it's tough that coming forward
basically the applicants seeking
agreement to the access so it can then
bring the development on site and comply
of the neighborhood plan and supply the
housing so I'll leave it there do we
know I don't I don't know that chair but
it's it's obviously come about as part
of the a neighborhood planet winter
referendum so we don't have anyone else
here except I have a short statement
from the ward men oh wait a minute do we
want questions of the officer sorry
but bear in mind this is outline and it
is for access did I see somebody's home
council field and then councillor
Madison just a number of dwellings
bearing in mind a discussion we had
earlier today I noticed neighbor
appliances 32 to 45 dwellings this
proposes 28 Wellings and we were
approving access I guess for 20 I
dwellings but does that mean at some
subsequent time we're gonna get detailed
application for some considerably larger
number having this for 28 or correct on
the second it's described as the 20 I do
link so it can't be any more than that
and the reserve matter stage it would
have to be 28 to unex if they want to
change that I have a fresh outline or
full application for a different number
of doing
I think that's been a mistake that's
gone on in the past that when it's had
up to and then it's gone less or more
and we've gotten a muddle when we've
come through for reserved matters so as
marks quite clearly stated it is now 28
Wellings you are not changing it unless
you wish to change it I don't wish to
change it particularly but what it could
be an idea to ask the applicant to
ensure that any subsequent development
he's substantially in agreement with the
the whatever the imaginary plan that we
were saving so if only does that um so
this application is 28 there is nothing
in the planning legislation stopping
anyone else but and planning up another
planning application in for more or less
we then have to consider that
application on its own merits similar to
what we did on item 1 earlier today but
it was a Mathers application in
association with this outline
application can only be for 28 houses
just to clarify them any further
questions did I see your hand councillor
Matheson wasn't it this is for questions
for the officer yes sorry yes I remember
now
yeah that does that land have any
significant slope in any direction it
does councilman thank you for pointing
that out if we could just look at
presentation it does it does slope up
look at photographs it slopes out the
front from the road basically yes from
the south to the north it slopes upwards
it's you can see the slope it's not it's
not overly pronounced so we just get a
photograph up
[Music]
I mean that gives some indication it's
not the best to be honest with you but
it's up to the left it does sloka way
bit it's not the best fact I'll just
show you how that works but but take it
from me it does slope up Jimmy just
point out on there where the access is
likely to be again please basically it's
for yes council of all vote is it
possible at this stage to put in one of
the recommendations that the use of
renewable materials
I'm getting in my ear you can but what
do you mean by renewable materials in
the sense that we looked at an earlier
planets top and which commented that
they just remember that the development
was using energy efficiently and that
put in place measures to above
recommendations but hadn't been using
renewable materials in terms of building
materials this would lower its carbon
footprint
there's not really a policy to support
that counts that that's that's problem
we have their ups off but they
statements in the NPP F but were we to
insist on it and then the applicant
appeal the condition I don't know what
we would say so at the moment they're
saying there's no policy or anything
that we can back that up on can we put
it as an informative note at this stage
is it of any value
we'll just think to see if we can find
something to add to your thoughts I mean
it's just a thought that the local plans
out forum comment public consultation
you might want to consider doing
something along those lines in there
yeah but if we haven't got anything in
place now we can't sort of impose it
Jones just having a look see if there's
anything in the neighborhood like we're
trying out
no we haven't got anything we can insist
on
so where do we can we have some advice
on that please from the legal side sorry
am i on now yes the planning officers
advice is it would be if I'm hearing
right we've we'd have to base it on
something rather thin in the MPPs I mean
yeah without worry more actually yes if
it's inconsistent decision it is not
your officers advice to Percy go down
that road in respect of seeking a scheme
to be renewable it has repercussions in
terms of what is the viability of the
scheme that would have to be tested it
also has no policy basis currently in
terms of the local plan position we're
at at this moment in time in the new
joint local plan there's from bits and
pieces about passive house design
building for life and so on that
possibly we can pull into it might have
to go through that a bit more in detail
but in our current situation it is not
something I'd recommend and it would be
very inconsistent with many other
decisions taking place across the
district so matheson a question yeah I
mean strangely similar similar terms
actually except that I've got I've got a
policy it's this the is this the right
time outline 22.2 n PP f 148 than 150
which do actually talk particularly
about using the the site and the
orientation of the site to improve its
energy performance 148 and 150 when
layout is part of the discussion which
would be in the reserve matters and the
orientation of the buildings would be
part of that that possibly would be more
appropriate time to
have that debate and discuss as neatly
so you've asked the question I don't
need to debate on it John at the moment
if I wanted to so I was just to ask John
whether it would be helpful as an
informative rather than that the the
applicant goes away and does the
reserved matters application and then we
come back and say oh well why didn't you
do so-and-so well I'm getting from the
legal office and not necessary at this
point so I think there's a great deal to
be achieved by I'm I'm happy to put an
informative and informative especially a
message to the applicant for yourselves
and your message in this case is please
can you consider the provisions of that
part of the MPP f1 or in in your
discussions and pre-application advice
perhaps in respect of potential layout
of the future scientists analyst is not
good okay so we've done with that then
and we can go into debate very shortly I
hope and I have a message here from
Julie Flatman I'm in meetings all
morning and afternoon so would you just
say the ward member is in support of the
application as per the neighbourhood
plan policy Strad 15 which we had up
here I would strongly advise the
developer to discuss the design with the
parish council to ensure full planning
permission achieved with ease which is
sort of coming down that same route but
with that little addition we can pop
that on so we're now open for discussion
and so does anybody want to start us off
councillor Matheson well done yeah yeah
I think the the you know given given
that the parish councils some support
I'd like to propose approval with that
informative that we've just discussed I
think that's very adequate can we put
that down yeah good thank you very much
to anybody else will speak councillor
field quite happy to second that that
sounds good enough anybody went to want
to say anything else
in that case I have a proposer in the
seconder with an informative note
regarding the MPP after issues yeah one
four eight two one fifty so with all
those in favor please vote thank you
very much we are unanimous and thank you
for everybody's attention today that was
very long and very well done thank you
very much indeed